Das Rasenfunk Tribünengespräch.
Hallo und herzlich willkommen zum Tribünengespräch. Ja, es ist wahr, ihr hört richtig, es gibt wieder ein Tribünengespräch. Kaum zu glauben, aber wahr und wir begrüßen euch herzlich und freuen uns, dass ihr uns jetzt hört. Und wenn ich wir sage, dann erfahrt ihr das zweite Unfassbare. Ich habe wieder meinen Frank an meiner Seite, den Co-Moderator, den ihr euch alle ständig wünscht, der Mann, der eine Stimme hat, wie ein warmes D-Dur gespielt von Bratschen. Hallo Frank!
Jetzt werde ich doch noch nervös. Hallo Max. Vielen Dank für die warmen Worte.
Ja, vollkommen zu Recht. Wie schön ist das, dass wir endlich mal wieder zusammen moderieren. Und nervös muss ich nicht sein, mein Lieber. Auch wenn es schon eine Weile her ist. Ja, ihr könnt dem Frank bei Twitter folgen als athelmi und ich bin bei Twitter der atgnetzer und wir haben, wie immer im Tribünengespräch, ein Thema, das die gesamte Sendung durchziehen soll und mit dem wir uns ausführlich beschäftigen. Und vielleicht hat sich der eine oder andere schon gefragt, was sucht jetzt Nobby Dickel in diesem Intro? Und das ist so ein bisschen der Grund, warum wir ihn reingeschnitten haben, liegt in unserem Thema begründet. Wer hätte es gedacht? Und das erklären wir euch am besten vielleicht, indem wir euch unseren Gast vorstellen. Wir freuen uns sehr, dass sie mit dabei ist. Giuseppina Dolle, eine Rasenfunk-Hörerin und Bayern-Fan und schon ganz lange im Fußball aktiv. Und warum das etwas Besonderes, erklären wir alles gleich. Aber erstmal sagen wir Hallo Pina, schön, dass du mit dabei bist.
Ja, hallo ihr beiden. Freut mich, dass ich die Ehre habe, Gast im Tribünengespräch zu sein.
Ja, Wahnsinn in Nummer 4. Das ist tatsächlich eine Ehre. So viele Gäste hatten wir noch nicht.
Ne, das stimmt. Und vor allem, dass Frank jetzt auch dazu gekommen ist, wenn er die ganze Zeit nicht dabei war, dann vielen Dank. Liegt wohl auch an mir.
Ja, vielen Dank für deinen dabei sein. Das ist tatsächlich uns eine große Ehre und ich freue mich sehr auf das Thema.
Womit wir die Überleitung gebracht haben, denn wir müssen euch das Thema noch verraten. Vielleicht kann ich es am besten damit erzählen, wie wir zwei Pina uns kennengelernt haben. Du hast mich irgendwann angerufen, um mir Feedback auf den Rasenfunk zu geben.
Genau. Ja, das war so, dass ich nicht Twitter und mich in diese Diskussion nicht eingebracht habe bisher und immer so gedacht habe. Also ich höre jetzt Rasenfunk seit – oder Schlusskonferenz und die Tribünengespräche – seit, ich glaube, April, Mai letzten Jahres. Und wollte immer mal Feedback geben, weil ich einfach die Sendung toll fand. Oder oft gab es Situationen, wo ich so gedacht habe, oh, Max sagt genau das, was ich auch denke und irgendwie würde ich es ihm ja gerne mal rückmelden. Und Mail war mir aber irgendwie zu blöd und dann habe ich mich mal getraut, anzurufen.
Genau.
Dann haben wir telefoniert.
Genau, sehr nett haben wir telefoniert. In meiner Erinnerung war es ein Sonntagvormittag, glaube ich. Und man mag sich ja fragen, die meisten Leute geben mir über Twitter Feedback. Du hast schon gesagt, du bist nicht bei Twitter. Und das hat mehrere Gründe. Aber einer der Gründe ist, dass du blind bist. Und das fand ich sehr interessant, als du mir erzählt hast, wie lange du schon Fußball verfolgst. Und da haben sich so viele Fragen gegeben, dass ich gesagt habe, Pina, als wir so 20 Minuten, glaube ich, nur darüber geredet haben, habe ich gesagt, lass uns da draußen Tribünengespräch machen. Und deswegen wollen wir uns damit heute beschäftigen. Magst du uns vielleicht am Anfang kurz einfach ein bisschen zu deinem Hintergrund erzählen? Also seit wann bist du Fußballfan? Wie kommt das? Bist du schon von Geburt an blind, damit wir so ein bisschen wissen, mit wem wir hier reden?
Ja, okay. Nur eine Sache, damit die Leute nicht denken, nur weil man blind ist, twittert man nicht. Das hat auch wirklich mit persönlichen Entscheidungen zu tun, bevor da vielleicht irgendein Blinder sitzt und sagt, was hat sie denn? Man kann doch twittern. So, also das ist jetzt mein persönlicher Grund, dass ich in den sozialen Medien nicht so zuhause bin. Ja, ich habe angeborenen grünen Star, Glaukom, habe die ersten vier, fünf Jahre noch was gesehen. Nicht vollständig, aber so, dass ich schon sehend gelernt habe, mich zu bewegen. Ich glaube, das ist schon auch ein großer Vorteil. Also räumliche Bewegung, Krabbeln, Laufen und so, das noch sehend gemacht zu haben, nach Dingen greifen. Ich kann mich noch erinnern an Farben. Also ich habe auch mit einem Tuschkasten gemalt und bloß als Kind, ja, lebt man ja sozusagen in seiner eigenen Welt und kriegt ja nicht so wirklich mit, was mit einem selber ist. Also für mich war so, wie ich bin, das alles ganz normal. Und insofern kann ich auch gar nicht so wirklich sagen, weil ich gar nichts mehr gesehen habe. Das ging so peu à peu zurück. Also es war schon so, dass der Regelkindergarten mich in meiner Heimatstadt Einbeck in der Nähe von Göttingen war. Eines Morgens durfte ich halt nicht mehr in den Kindergarten. Das ist so eine ganz einschneidende Situation, weil ich mich noch heulend auf der Treppe sitzen sah. Mein Nachbar, Junge Oliver, ging in den Kindergarten und ich durfte nicht mehr mit. Das war schon sehr einschneidend. Da war ich so drei, vier, wie das halt so ist, Kindergartenalter. Und in der Zeit war wohl auch schon von der damals zuständigen Blintenschule mit Internat in Hannover auch mal die Frühförderung bei uns zu Hause. Und ich bin dann relativ früh, nämlich eigentlich schon für die Vorschule, mit Ende vier Jahre dann ins Internat gegangen. Hab also die Biografie als Blinde wirklich durchlaufen an Blintenschulen und würde mal sagen, dass das Sehen so mit fünf, sechs so dann irgendwann weg war. Also meine Anfangszeit in Hannover, da weiß ich noch, bin ich noch nach irgendwelchen Spielsachen, die andere runtergeschmissen haben, hinterher gekrabbelt und hab das wohl auch noch ein bisschen gesehen. Aber wann es weg war, weiß ich nicht, weil es so ist, dass ich ein sehr gutes, ausgeprägtes Gehör habe und eigentlich erst viel später durch den zunehmenden Intellekt, den man dann ja halt irgendwann hat, mitgekriegt habe, dass ich eben auch mit geschlossenen Augen nicht gegen eine Wand oder gegen geparkte Autos oder so gelaufen bin. Also dass das eben was auch mit Hören zu tun hat. Insofern ist das wirklich auch für meine Umwelt. Also auch meine Eltern können jetzt nicht sagen oder meine Mutter, wann es jetzt genau so war. Also ich tippe mal so mit sechs. Ja und Fußball, um die zweite Frage aufzugreifen. Ja, also ich kann mich erinnern, dass ich das erste Mal mit Fußball konfrontiert wurde. Das muss dann wohl um die WM 74 gewesen sein. Allerdings nicht mit dem Spiel, sondern nur mit diesem Lied. Fußball ist unser Leben. Ich kann mich erinnern, dass ich im Internat mit meiner Melodica dieses Lied gespielt habe, ohne Bezug zum Fußball. Ich habe einen drei Jahre jüngeren Bruder, der sehend ist und ich kann mich an das erste einschneidende Erlebnis erinnern. Das war 1978, das Endspiel Argentinien gegen Holland. Da war ich sehr betroffen, dass der arme holländische verletzte Mensch mit der Trage vom Platz getragen werden musste und dann die armen Holländer noch verloren haben. Das hat mich sehr traurig gemacht. Ich konnte mit den Feiern in Argentinien überhaupt nichts anfangen und ich habe mit meinem Bruder anschließend immer wieder dieses Spiel nachgespielt und dann musste natürlich Holland gewinnen. Das war so das einschneidende Erlebnis Fußball, das Länderspiel, das ich da halt wohl irgendwie mitgekriegt habe. Dann kommt so eine Episode zwei Jahre, wo ich gar nicht genau weiß, wie es gekommen ist. Also ich kann sagen bei der Europameisterschaft in Belgien war ich fit, was Spieler angeht, was auf dem Platz angeht. Und in der Zeit im Internat war es halt so, ich sag mal in Hannover, es gab halt HSV und Bayern, also irgendwelche Gestalten. Da gab es vielleicht so einen, der irgendwie Kaiserslautern-Fan war, ansonsten gab es aber HSV und Bayern. Und ich bin irgendwie durch eine Freundin, vielleicht auch so durch die Bravo, die man natürlich dann auch als junges Mädel gelesen hat. Wir hatten ja Mitschüler, die noch was gucken konnten, die haben das dann halt vorgelesen und so. Irgendwie bin ich halt Rummenigge-Fan geworden. So und Rummenigge hat bei Bayern gespielt, ja, da blieb dann ja nichts anderes. Also ich war Karlo-Rumenigge-Fan und fand aber…
Interessiert sich also nicht nur für Fußball, sondern auch für Uhren. Was hab ich? Er hat doch Uhren importiert, die er geschenkt bekommen hätte und musste mitbekommen.
Das war ja schon die Zeit, da hatte ich mit Rummenigge gar nichts mehr am Hut. Ich hatte dann ja mit ganz anderen Leuten nicht hin.
Ja, lass uns mal, bevor du da ins Schwärmen kommst und wir die 80er besprechen, lassen uns nochmal zum Anfang zurückkommen, denn mich würde interessieren, Fußball ist ja ein sehr visuelles Spiel und mir fällt das einfach schwer, mir das vorzustellen, das alles nicht sehen zu können. Hast du denn eine Erinnerung noch, dass du mal Fußball gesehen hast als Kind? Oder ist das, findet das komplett in deinem Kopf statt?
Das findet komplett in meinem Kopf statt. Es findet durch das statt, was ich höre und da ich mich ja durch das Sehen nicht ablenken lasse, höre ich sehr gut und merke auch sehr gut, was da gesprochen wird, merke mir sehr gut. Ich habe gerade in der Zeit dann in Hannover natürlich und vor allem, als ich 1981 dann auch noch nach Marburg auf eine andere Schule gewechselt bin, Gymnasium für Blinde und Sehbehinderte, war ich ein absoluter Fußballradio-Junkie. Also ich habe alles gehört, was es da gab und es ist mit heute nicht wirklich zu vergleichen, weil es wirklich sehr, sehr viele auch verschiedene Formate gab. Also gerade auch der Bayerische Rundfunk und WDR, die ich dann ja auch alle, als ich in Hessen war, hören konnte. Da habe ich einfach ganz, ganz viel natürlich Spielreportagen gehört. Da gab es einfach auch mehr Fußballsendungen noch am Wochenende. Freitagsabends ging es los, es gab Mittwochsabends eine Sendung, Samstagnachmittag, Sonntagnachmittag und die waren weniger, ich sage jetzt mal so, wie sie heute sind. Also wenn man heute zumindest hier oben im NDR 2 die Nachmittagsshow hört, dann ja Kurznachrichten, dann Kurzeinblendungen von den Spielen, Musik. Ich habe den Eindruck, damals wurde länger eingeblendet. Und wurde auch, ja. Einfach das Thema Fußball war einfach mehr. Also irgendwie Interviews vor dem Spiel, nach dem Spiel gibt es natürlich heute irgendwie auch noch, aber es war, ja es war anders. Und ich habe wirklich auch zum Leidwesen meiner Familie, auch in den Sommerferien, wenn andere dann ins Freibad gegangen sind, als es eben noch keinen Walkman mit Radio gab, ich bin zu Hause geblieben, ich musste meine Radiosendungen hören. Und natürlich dann auch Fernsehen. Das ging dann los, alles im Radio und dann Sportschau, Sportstudio. Ich habe im Internat samstagsabends immer gelitten, wenn ich mich nicht durchsetzen konnte, in dem Internatsaufenthaltsraum das Sportstudio gucken zu dürfen. Irgendwann gab es dann einen kleinen eigenen Fernsehen, weil ja, das waren schon immer Kämpfe. Ja, also insofern, ich habe es im Prinzip durch Beschreibungen erlebt. Ich habe angefangen, das gehört auch noch dazu, dass ich mit einem speziellen Lesegerät, was es Anfang der 80er gab, das nennt sich Optakon. Es war kein sprechendes Lesegerät, wie sie heute auf dem Markt sind, sondern das ist ein Gerät, wo man eine Handkamera hat, die man über das Schriftgut führt und den Finger hat man auf dem Gerät, auf so einem Lesefeld. Und durch elektronische Vibrationen von so komischen Metallstiften bekommt man sozusagen den Kontrast, also die Schrift, als Vibration auf den Zeigefinger, auf die Zeigefingerkuppe. Also das heißt, Voraussetzung ist, dass ich die Schwarzschriftbuchstaben gelernt habe, also dass ich die konnte. Und ja, ich habe eben Unterricht in Hannover in diesem Lesen mit diesem Gerät bekommen und habe dann natürlich den Kicker gelesen. Und einer dieser Lehrer hat mir damals ein Fußballfeld taktil auf so einem Blatt gezeichnet, dass ich also wusste, wo sind die Tore, wo sind die Eckfahnen, wie ist das mit dem Spielfeld, mit der Aufteilung, Strafraum und so.
Faszinierend, wie man da vor allem rankommen kann. Du hast ja eben jetzt auch gesagt, dass die Radiosendungen früher viel Fußball fokussierter waren. Das, glaube ich, kann jeder nachvollziehen, ist tatsächlich auch so. Wie wichtig sind denn dann heute auch so Sachen wie Podcasts für dich? Und ich meine jetzt gar nicht nur klassische Podcasts, also richtige Podcasts, wie jetzt den Rasenfunk, sondern auch die Tatsache, dass Radiosendungen nachträglich abrufbar sind. Ich kann mir vorstellen, wenn man viel und gerne Radio konsumiert, ist das doch eigentlich dann ja auch ein großer Gewinn.
Es ist ein großer Gewinn, aber für mich einfach nicht machbar. Ich habe die Zeit nicht. Also ich selber habe gar keine Podcasts und ich höre auch längst nicht mehr so viel Radio. Für mich ist durch die neuen Medien, um da schon mal vorzugreifen, ich sage jetzt mal seit, bezogen jetzt auf den Fußball seit etwa so 2000, 2001, sind für mich die Newsletter sehr wichtig geworden. Ich bin zufällig mal über eine Geschichte im Internet über den Spiegel irgendwie auf den Link freistoß.de gekommen. Damals der Pressespiegel, den Oliver Fritsch in Gießen damals mit ins Leben gerufen hat, wo ja Zeitungsartikel aus der sogenannten kritischen Zeitpresse, also Süddeutsche Zeitung, Frankfurt, FAZ damals und FR und so, also wo im Prinzip mittels des Newsletters ein Pressespiegel konnte man abonnieren und das war für mich wirklich die tolle Möglichkeit, nicht irgendwie im Internet selber recherchieren zu müssen, sondern letztlich anhand dieser ausgewählten Artikel dann tatsächlich, wenn mich das interessiert hat, den Link anzuklicken und so auf den original ausführlichen Artikel zu kommen und da habe ich einfach ganz, ganz viele Sachen erfahren. Und später kamen dann ja noch Focus-Fußball dazu und 11 Freunde-Newsletter und ich komme oft nicht dazu, das alles zu lesen, aber eine Zeit lang, gerade als ich auch keine Arbeit hatte, habe ich viel gelesen und bin dadurch dann einfach auch auf so andere Dinge gestoßen, die man ja sonst über Radio und Fernsehen kaum mitkriegt. Also ich sage mal Stichwort Hartplatz-Helden, das ist eine Geschichte, die habe ich von Anfang an mit Unterschriftenliste und dann später auch mit Spenden und sowas mit unterstützt. Das kam ja erst viel später, ja, sage ich jetzt mal ins ZDF und in die Öffentlichkeit. Oder eben auch dieses Thema Blogger, da hätte ich ja sonst auch nie was von mitgekriegt. Ob das jetzt Jens Weinreich oder sonst wie Leute sind, jetzt Fokus Fußball auch. Also insofern, das spielt für mich eine wichtigere Rolle. Und damals war es aber tatsächlich, um dann nochmal auf die 80er Jahre zurückzukommen, einmal tatsächlich das Radio und wirklich damals eben der Kicker, wo dann auch ich mir auch montags ganz viel habe vorlesen lassen, dann von den Betreuern im Internat, so meine Artikel, die mich interessiert haben. Also jeder, der sich irgendwie nie für Fußball interessiert hat, durch den Kontakt zu mir, ja, ist er dann, habe ich häufiger erlebt, dann plötzlich doch irgendwie selber interessiert geworden. Durch dieses Vermitteln dann.
Aber jetzt würde mich interessieren, was ist denn dann das, was dich für den Fußball so fasziniert hat? Denn wenn ich drüber nachdenke, was mich so ein Fußballfan gemacht hat, dann hat das halt ganz, ganz viel mit Visuellem zu tun. Also fängt an natürlich bei besonders tollen Toren, bei der Geschwindigkeit, dann natürlich auch bei dem, dass man selber spielen kann und ehrlich gesagt geht es aber auch weiter bei Frisuren. Also Michael Steinkopf wird immer ein Held meiner Jugend bleiben, weil da bin ich einfach zum Fußballfan geworden. Was reizt dich denn so am Fußball?
Die Psychologie und die Menschen. Und jetzt komme ich nämlich zu dem Punkt, was für mich auch so ein einschneidendes Erlebnis war. Ich hatte ja am Anfang gesagt, dass ich eben ja so für Rummenicke und Nationalmannschaft dann auch Magath und Karls und so, die fand ich alle am Anfang toll. Und dann habe ich ein einschneidendes Erlebnis gehabt. Es gab im Bayerischen Rundfunk Bayern 1 mittwochs abends eine halbstündige Sendung, die nannte sich Sport Prisma oder so ähnlich. Da haben die immer ein halbstündiges Gespräch mit einzelnen Leuten geführt. Und damals habe ich zufällig dann ein Gespräch mit Paul Czerny gehört. Und den fand ich in diesem Gespräch so beeindruckend, also wie er gesprochen hat, was er erzählt hat, dass ich seit dem Zeitpunkt – das muss so 1982 gewesen sein, Saison 82, 83 – ich habe dieses Gespräch leider nie mehr bekommen. Ich habe nochmal nach Midschneid gefragt und so. Da habe ich angefangen, mich für die sogenannten Wasserträger zu interessieren. Ich war überhaupt nicht mehr so Fan von den Leuten, die permanent in der Öffentlichkeit standen. Ich fand es viel interessanter, Statements von anderen Leuten zu hören. Ich habe angefangen, bei Bayern dann alles, was ich an Interviews gehört habe, aufzunehmen. Ich habe einen ganzen Kassettenkoffer voll. Ich warte darauf, dass ich irgendwann mal in Rente bin, ein bedienbares Digitalisierungsgerät habe und dann vielleicht mal anfange, diese Kassetten durchzuhören, was da noch drauf ist, weil ich wirklich alles mitgeschnitten habe, was ich im Radio an O-Tönen bekommen habe nachspielen und Anfang der 90er Jahre auch noch im Fernsehen von Bayern. Da sind bestimmt interessante Sachen drauf und ich habe zum Beispiel auch mal, das war bei dem Pokal-Endspiel Bayern München gegen Mönchengladbach 1984, also die Woche vorher, letzter Bundesligaspieltag, da habe ich mich fürchterlich drüber geärgert, dass Bayern 1 permanent die gleichen Leute interviewt hat nach Spielen, weil die halt immer in der Öffentlichkeit standen und dann habe ich nach der Sendung, nach heute im Stadion, den Siegfried Schuler angerufen und habe ihn gefragt, warum sie denn nicht mal andere Leute interviewen, so wie Dürrenberger oder wen auch immer und ja, beim Pokalspiel in Frankfurt, er hat dann gesagt, er ist dann selber da, haben sie es tatsächlich gemacht und es gibt auch einen O-Ton, wo er sagt, ja heute wollen wir auch mal ein paar andere Leute interviewen. Also das fand ich, sowas habe ich übrigens häufig gemacht, dass ich eben bei bestimmten Situationen, die mich geärgert haben oder gefreut haben oder so auch Briefe an die entsprechenden Leute geschrieben habe.
Wir haben jetzt die ganze Zeit darüber gesprochen, dass du Fußball natürlich im Fernsehen hörend konsumiert hast, im Radio, sogar die Interviews aufgezeichnet, was ich sehr faszinierend finde. Wäre mir sicherlich interessant, die mal alle zu hören in der heutigen Zeit, vor allem mit dem zeitlichen Abstand.
Und für Intros dabei rausspringen würden für den Rasenfunk, Frank.
Ich fürchte bloß, dass ich manche O-Töne gar nicht mehr zuordnen kann, weil ja nicht immer gesagt wird, wenn ich dann zu spät drauf gedruckt habe.
Das wird wahrscheinlich wirklich schwer, wenn es da mal nicht um die bekannten Köpfe geht. Jetzt haben wir aber sehr viel davon gesprochen, wie du Fußball aus der Entfernung wahrgenommen hast. Irgendwann war ja mit Sicherheit dann auch der Reiz, da ins Stadion zu gehen. Wo hat denn das begonnen? War der erste Stadionbesuch eher bei der Kreisligamannschaft um die Ecke oder tatsächlich auf der großen Bühne?
Nein, das kam später mit der Kreisliga. Das ist sozusagen eher der Schluss. Nein. Also ich habe mir immer, immer, immer, immer gewünscht, dass irgendwann mal jemand mit mir in die Südkurve geht, ins Olympiastadion. Meine Mutter selber war in einer eher schwierigeren Erziehungssituation, so alleinerziehend und auch kein Geld und so. Also von zu Hause aus ist das bis, ist das nicht erfolgt, diese Erfüllung des Wunsches. Ich habe dann damals in Marburg im Internat an der Blindenstudienanstalt ja dann einfach auch dem Wunsch geäußert, ich möchte so gerne mal zum Fußball. Und dann gab es diese super Situation, dass es in der ersten Hauptrunde DFB-Pokal 85, die Bayern in Offenbach gespielt haben. Und dann hat der Betreuer zu mir gesagt, ja dann ruf in Offenbach an und guck, ob du Karten kriegst. Dann fahren wir hin. Na ja und dann habe ich das dann eben auch machen müssen, mich zu trauen, anzurufen und zu sagen, ja ich bin hier Schülerin an der Blindschule und würde gerne zum Spiel gegen Bayern. Und ja dann habe ich also, haben wir Karten bekommen und dann ist ein Betreuer mit, ja es waren glaube ich noch zwei oder drei Jungs dabei, die auch Fußball-Bayern-Fan waren. Wir sind dann zu dem Spiel im August 85. Das war dann mein erstes Live-Spiel im Stadion, Kikas Offenbach gegen Bayern München, glaube 1 zu 3.
Für die Bayern?
Ja, na klar. Also ich habe ja gesagt, Offenbach gegen Bayern, ne? 1 zu 3.
Ja da will ich jetzt aber noch mehr wissen. Wie war denn das? Also es ist ganz schwierig, sich das vorzustellen, also zumindest mir fällt es echt schwer, weil das muss einen doch vollkommen erschlagen, all die Eindrücke, die man da akustisch wahrnimmt.
Also ich kann das auch gar nicht mehr so wirklich von diesem Spiel jetzt sagen, ich kann das natürlich in einer Rückschau auf viele andere Spiele sagen, was mich eben so begeistert und beeindruckt hat. Wie soll ich sagen, also die ganze Atmosphäre im Stadion, ich bekomme, also am liebsten bin ich, das ist auch heute noch so im Stehblock, ich kriege durch das Drumherum, durch die Atmosphäre, durch die Reaktionen um mich herum irgendwie auch ein Gespür für das Spiel. Also natürlich muss ich immer jemanden haben, der die Reportage macht, also meine sehende Begleitung dann sozusagen, muss erzählen, was da passiert, aber ja, es ist erstens toll, diese verschiedenen Gesänge zu hören, da hat sich ja auch massiv was verändert, können wir ja vielleicht nachher auch noch mal was dazu sagen, ja, also klar, die Lautstärke ist manchmal schon erdrückend, vor allem jetzt in den neuen Stadien, finde ich das auch nicht immer lustig, wie man da zugedröhnt wird, weil wenn man nicht sieht und dann auch noch die Ohren sozusagen zugedröhnt werden, dann ist man halt irgendwie im Baku oben so fast, hat irgendwie keine Möglichkeit der Orientierung und weiß noch nicht mal, dass man angesprochen wird oder wer einen anspricht oder so, das ist dann schon irgendwie schwierig. Der Weg ist natürlich auch interessant. Interessant im Sinne von, manchmal ist es unangenehm, wenn es eben so voll ist und man zerquetscht wird. Andererseits ist es auch interessant, ja wahrzunehmen, was einfach für Leute so drumrum sind. Und ich war vor allem in den 90er Jahren sehr, sehr regelmäßig beim Fußball, sowohl in der ersten Liga als auch bei den Bayern-Amateuren und später auch bei Unterhaching. Und dann einfach auch so mitzukriegen, ja was, also wie kreativ zum Teil sind einfach die Fans mit ihren Sprüchen, mit ihren Gesängen, mit ihren Kommentaren zu irgendwelchen Dingen. Das hat es halt auch ausgemacht. Und ich habe einfach durch mein eigenes Dasein natürlich auch anders sein, ganz, ganz interessante Menschen auch in diesen Fußballsituationen kennengelernt. Sowohl jetzt auf Fanseite, ja als auch dann eben auch in Kontakt mit manchen Beteiligten.
Ich würde gleich nochmal ganz gerne auf – du hast es gerade eben kurz angesprochen, dass sich die Gesänge verändert haben und hast jetzt auch gesagt, dass diese Kommentare der Fans – und ich nehme mal an, du meinst jetzt nicht nur die Kommentare derjenigen, die direkt neben dir stehen, sondern auch eben die Äußerungen der Fans in der Masse. Was hat sich denn verändert da über die Jahre? Waren es nur die Gesänge oder ist es tatsächlich so auch insgesamt die Stimmung und die Reaktion der Fans auf Geschehnisse im Spiel?
Also ich finde heute – ich sage immer, eigentlich ist es heute nur noch irgendwie, wir wandern zu einem Event-Tempel. Also wenn man sich anguckt, wie die Wege zur Allianz Arena, wenn man zum Stadion geht, dann die Leute bleiben stehen, machen Fotos, sind mit ihren Smartphones beschäftigt, mit Selfies und keine Ahnung was. In den 90er Jahren war es so, wenn ich Richtung Olympiastadion gegangen bin oder auch mit den Bayern-Amateuren unterwegs war, es wurde schon in der S-Bahn gesungen. Und zwar nicht irgendwie nur drei Leute, sondern man ging singend Richtung Stadion. Ich kann mich an ein Spiel erinnern, das muss so 1993, 94 gewesen sein, April oder so, also es war schönes Wetter, Olympiastadion, Bayern gegen Dortmund, da war ein riesengroßes Zelt irgendwie aufgebaut, auf der einen Seite standen die Dortmund-Fans, auf der anderen Seite standen die Bayern-Fans und die haben sich die Gesänge um die Ohren gehauen. Und zwar nicht immer nur dasselbe, sondern jeder hat sein Liedgut, also die haben sich sozusagen mit ihrem Liedgut schon in Anführungsstrichen bekämpft. Und im Stadion ist es doch heute so, man sehen doch den Anpfiff herbei, damit nicht nur das Spiel losgeht, sondern damit endlich die Kurven was tun können, weil vorher wird man doch zugedröhnt. Ich habe im Olympiastadion in der Südkurve damals, wir haben ab halb zwei, viertel vor zwei im Stadion gestanden, weil man erstens früh sein da sein musste, um irgendwie noch einen adäquaten Platz zu finden, wo man einigermaßen gut stehen und der Begleiter gucken konnte. Aber man hat in der Zeit auch gesungen, obwohl damals natürlich auch schon Interviews und Werbung und so was war, aber das geht doch heute alles gar nicht mehr. Und dann finde ich einfach auch, ich fand es immer interessant in München jede Saison festzustellen, was haben sie sich jetzt wieder ausgedacht. Und ich finde es im Moment ziemlich nervig, dass meistens ein und dasselbe Lied dann von den Ultras oder von wem auch immer eine ganze Halbzeit geleiert wird, wo es so viel Repertoire gibt. Ja und das finde ich mittlerweile einfach ja enttäuschend. Und ich finde es schade, dass es eben so ja dieser Fußball und dieses ja gemeinsame da zusammen hingehen und singen und so, dass es einfach nicht mehr ist.
Ja ich fand es auch kürzlich erst bemerkenswert als ein Kommentator bei einem Spiel gesagt hat, hier ich kann gar nicht mal sagen um welches Stadion es ging, aber er hat so was gesagt wie hier kommt man immer gerne hin, hier gibt es spielbezogene Support. Richtig. Das ist heute schon etwas erwähnenswertes. Tatsächlich der Sing-Sang, der oft aus den Kurven zu hören ist, der überhaupt nicht spielbezogen ist, hat sich so ein bisschen eingeschlichen und nachvollziehbar.
Genau und dann finde ich noch interessant, was sich auch verändert hat, also zumindest in meiner Wahrnehmung war das so, ich meine, ich finde das mit den ganzen Bengalos und so auch alles nur gefährlich und schwierig, aber ich kann mich erinnern, dass ich war zu 92, 25. September muss das gewesen sein, beim Abendspiel in Dortmund und ich habe damals, als ich zum Fußball gegangen bin, immer auch, und das mache ich heute auch noch, so ein Fotoapparat dabei und lasse meine Begleitungen fotografieren, weil natürlich, wenn ich mich mit Sehenden über Fußball unterhalte, das natürlich für die viel griffiger ist, wenn es dazu noch Fotos gibt und irgendwie keine Tonaufnahmen, die ich mir früher auch gemacht habe.
Das ist ja verrückt, das heißt, du machst das Anderen Sehenden leichter.
Ja, aber ich habe da ja auch Spaß dran, mit denen mich darüber auszutauschen und ich weiß ja, was da drauf zu sehen sein soll. Und da war das zum Beispiel so, dass wir da auch solche, so ein Bengalos, wie man heute sagen würde, auch fotografiert haben. Also, dass das toll ausgesehen haben soll, diese farbenfrohen, ja, Feuer oder was auch immer man da in der Kurve gesehen hat. So, also insofern muss es das ja in den 90er Jahren auch schon gegeben haben, aber scheinbar irgendwie anders oder nicht so, ich weiß es nicht. Nicht so kriminalisiert oder keine Ahnung.
Ich war damals leider noch nicht im Stadion, deswegen erlaube ich mir da kein Urteil zu. Wir wollen auch jetzt keine Ultra- und Bengalo-Sendung draus machen. Aber was ich schon interessant finde, ist, dass du sagst, du gehst bewusst gerne in den Steeblock, denn ich hätte vermutet, wenn man irgendwo stolpern kann oder es ein bisschen unruhig zugeht und manchmal wird da ja auch wirklich gedrängelt geschubst und manchmal tanzt man ja auch zusammen, hätte ich gedacht, dass man mit einer Sehbehinderung sich nicht unbedingt in den Steeblock stellt. Wie reagiert denn so dein Umfeld, wenn du in Stadion gehst? Wie war es denn früher und hat sich das zu heute verändert?
Also erstmal das mit dem Stolpern und so ist nicht so wirklich das Problem. Das ist dann eher so die Denke der Sehenden, die einfach sich nicht vorstellen können, wie man eben als Blinder sozusagen ja Stufen und alles Mögliche bewältigt. Für mich ist eher das Problem, die Treppe zu finden, als sie zu laufen. Das ist immer so der entscheidende Unterschied. Der Sehende denkt immer, ich habe mit dem Laufen der Stufen Probleme, aber die Probleme sind davor, um die Treppe zu finden. Also erstmal ist es so, dass ich natürlich nicht immer an der richtigen Stelle scheinbar rufe. Also bis derjenige mir gesagt hat, oder ich merke so, der Ball ist irgendwie jetzt fast vom Tor und ich habe dann immer so, ich brülle immer raus. Also ich will ja, dass der Ball da nicht reingeht vom Gegner. Also da gibt es schon so Situationen. Es gab schon mal so ein, zwei Situationen, wo Leute sich umgedreht haben und irgendwie auch so gesagt haben, was das denn irgendwie soll. Aber die meisten sind so, dass sie wohl erstmal gucken und wenn sie dann aber merken, dass ich eben genau auf ihrer Wellenlänge bin und auch Ahnung habe und so, dann ist so ganz schnell dieses Blindsein kein Thema mehr. Also ich habe gerade auch beim Fußball so gemerkt und da kommt man natürlich im Stehblock dann doch noch mal eher auch so ins Gespräch, dass ich da mich angenommen gefühlt habe. Das war einfach das Thema nicht, sondern das Thema war Fußball, der Ärger über den Schiri oder die Freude über das, was jetzt gerade passiert ist und das andere kam irgendwie erst hinten an. Und es ist so, ich habe einfach ganz viel in Bewegung gesetzt, um irgendwelche Spiele zu besuchen und ich habe dabei auch Dinge gemacht. Also da bin ich auch mit Leuten unterwegs gewesen, die wenig Ahnung hatten von meiner Mannschaft. Ich meine, wer kennt sich irgendwie in Hessen mit den Bayern-Amateuren aus? Wenn ich da jemanden mitnehme als Begleitung, der kann mir dann nur sagen, dass die jetzt am Ball sind, aber natürlich nicht die Namen. Und wenn ich was genauer wissen will, dann habe ich halt einfach den nächstbesten, der neben mir steht, Stand gefragt. Das mache ich heute auch noch so. Wenn meine Begleitung irgendwas nicht richtig sieht, dann frage ich den nächsten. Dann kriege ich auch eigentlich immer Antworten.
Das finde ich super. Da kann man auch ganz gut so eine Kompetenzanalyse seines aktuellen Staates und Umfelds machen. Da ist es vielleicht ganz gut, dass du im Stehbereich bist, liebe Pina. Lass dir das von jemanden sagen, der oft auch sitzen muss, weil er keine andere Karte kriegt. Da sitzen manchmal Leute um einen herum. Da ist es mit dem Fußballsachverstand nicht so arg weit.
Ja, ich meine, ich muss ja jetzt, also wenn ich die, wo ja sicherlich nachher auch noch drauf komme, die Kopfhörerplätze benutze, muss ich ja auch sitzen. Aber wenn ich jetzt eben so zu anderen Spielen gehe, ohne diese Karten, dann gehe ich halt ins Stehblock und das habe ich eben auch gemacht. Und vielleicht nochmal um diese, meine Stadionbesuche. Wir hatten ja gesagt, ich habe angefangen in Offenbach. Vielleicht noch so zwei, drei Stationen, bis es dann zu Regelmäßigkeit wurde, zu nennen, weil ich die auch ganz interessant finde. Also wie gesagt, das Pokalspiel war also das erste irgendwie interessantes Erlebnis, aber da war ich natürlich noch nicht so wirklich richtig drin. Und dann haben wir in der Jahrgangsstufe 13 eine Jahrgangsstufenfahrt mit ein paar Leuten nach England gemacht und waren dort in der Nähe von Norwich. Und wie das so ist, man sitzt abends im Pub und irgendwie meistens trifft dann irgendein anderer Blinde, andere Blinde. Also es kam ein blinder Engländer und kam dann mit uns ins Gespräch und ja dann ging es auch im Fußball und so. Und dann hat er wirklich uns, also es gab noch einen Klassenkamerad, der sich auch für Fußball interessiert hat, dann hat er uns Karten besorgt fürs Spiel Norwich City gegen Nottingham Forest. Ja und dann war ich im September 87 in England im Stadion und wir hatten einen so genialen Platz. Wir waren wirklich, das muss wohl irgendwie so eine Art, ja wie so keine Ahnung, Ehrentribüne. Also wir wurden da nicht irgendwie begrüßt oder so, aber das war wohl eher so der Bereich, wo eben auch Spielerfrauen oder geladene Gäste oder so, wir waren wirklich direkt am Spielfeldrand. Es war irre. Es war nur schade, dass Norwich verloren hat und ich war von der Stimmung so ein bisschen enttäuscht, weil ich natürlich bei England was ganz anderes erwartet hatte, aber die haben halt irgendwie 1-3 verloren und da war entsprechend dann natürlich nicht so viel los. Dann war ich 89 zum Rückrundenauftakt in Frankfurt. Schöne Grüße an Marvin. Das war also mein erstes Bundesliga-Spielen. Genau. Gegen Bayern damals, der Rückrundenauftakt. Ich glaube, das war das Spiel mit diesem, glaube ich mit dem Augenthaler Tor, aber ich bin mir nicht mehr so ganz sicher. Im Februar. Und dann wollte ich unbedingt, hatte ich ja gesagt, ins Olympiastadion. Und dann gab es eine Situation, ich hatte einen Lieblingsspieler, dessen Karriere ich von Anfang bis Ende verfolgt habe. Nämlich Hansi Flüglar. Da gab es eine Situation in einem Europapokalspiel, wo er mir das erste Mal aufgefallen ist und seitdem habe ich sozusagen seine Karriere beobachtet. Und der hatte nun 92 sein letztes Bundesligaspiel im Mai und ich musste dahin. Ich dachte, das geht gar nicht, wenn der verabschiedet wird. Ich muss ihn einmal, muss ich dabei gewesen sein. Und dann habe ich, ich habe damals in Kassel studiert und habe dann zu einem Fußball-Fan-Club in Kassel-Calden Kontakt aufgenommen und habe gesagt, ich bezahle alles, ich brauche nur eine Begleitung. Ich brauche eine Begleitung, ich will unbedingt zu diesem Spiel. Und dann haben die mir ein junges Mädel, 16- 17-jähriges Mädel vermittelt, die mit mir zu diesem Spiel gefahren ist. Und dieses Spiel wäre fast noch durch ÖTV-Streik ins Wasser gefallen. Also einen Abend vorher war ich bei dem Einbahnhof in Kassel, da haben sie gesagt, es fahren keine Züge und hätte ich nicht abends noch irgendwie im Fernsehen die Hessenschau gehört, wo es dann hieß, ab Wilhelmshöhe fahren doch ICEs am nächsten Tag, dann wären wir nicht gefahren. Und ja, dann habe ich die Melanie angerufen, die war aber schon aus Frust irgendwie dann in die Disco und die habe ich dann erst nachts erreicht. Also es war wirklich, also aufs Messersschneide. Und wir sind dann, ja, kann man sich heute auch gar nicht vorstellen, mit ICE hingefahren nach München, haben dann dieses Spiel, wo Flügler und Effenberg verabschiedet wurden, angeguckt. Das war gegen Duisburg auch ein Spiel, was wirklich alles in sich hatte. Ich glaube, sogar eine rote Karte und 11 Meter und ja, und sind auf dem Rückweg, weil es da keine ICEs mehr gab, dann mit dem D-Zug, das muss man sich mal vorstellen, mit dem D-Zug von München nach Göttingen gefahren und da hat uns dann ihre Mutter abgeholt nachts. Und in diesem Zug habe ich also auch wieder was ganz Ungewöhnliches kennengelernt. Da waren nämlich zwei Typen, die sind bis Augsburg mit uns gefahren. Ja, und die erzählten dann ganz locker, sie wären Huls. Und ich dachte, das ist was? Also ja, da habe ich also das erste Mal mit Hooligans gesprochen, die das dann auch wirklich so erzählten, Familienväter, aber am Wochenende wird sich gekloppt. Ja, also so viel zum Thema. Es gibt so ganz, ganz viele Facetten, die ich einfach an diesem Sport neben dem Spielgeschehen einfach so interessant finde. Ich habe im Studium Sozialwesen studiert, also ich bin diplomierte Sozialarbeiterin und Pädagogin und habe dann auch in den 90er-Jahren dann 95, als ich ein Thema für meine mündliche Prüfung brauchte, habe ich dann das Thema Fendtprojekte, da ging das ja damals los mit den sozialpädagogischen Fendtprojekten. Habe ich mir rausgesucht, habe das Fendtprojekt in Hannover bei Hannover 96 besucht und habe dazu eben meine mündliche Prüfung zu diesem Thema gemacht. Also insofern gab es ganz, ganz viele Themen, die mich sozusagen da auch immer irgendwie berührt und interessiert haben.
Jetzt hast du vorhin kurz angeschnitten mit den Kopfhörerplätzen. Wir werden ja gleich noch ausführlicher darauf eingehen, dass es heute ein weit verbreitetes Angebot für Blinde gibt mit Live-Reportagen im Stadion. Wie war denn das aber dann früher als die Anfänge, von denen du eben erzählt hast und dann auch die Jahre danach, du hast gesagt, da war immer eine Begleitung dabei, die dann so ein bisschen die Reportage übernommen hat. Wie gut geschult musste die denn sein oder wie geübt musste die denn sein? Ich kann mir das jetzt schwer vorstellen, ich bin auch kein regelmäßiger Stadiongänger, aber ich kann mir das doch ziemlich schwer vorstellen, wenn man ein Spiel quasi live mit kommentieren muss für jemanden, der neben einem steht.
Da kannst du nicht von Schulung sprechen, also ich habe jemanden gesucht, der mich begleitet und ich habe, wenn mir irgendwas nicht ausreichte, gefragt. Also da ging es einfach ganz klar darum und das ist schon dann auch irgendwie ein ganz großer Unterschied eben zu Menschen, die einfach gucken können, diese Flexibilität einfach mal loszugehen und zu sagen, ich mache das jetzt, ich habe jetzt Lust dahin zu gehen. Das gab es bei mir nicht, sondern ich musste mir das immer im Vorhinein organisieren und überlegen, ich habe da Sachen auch in Kauf genommen, wenn ich mir das jetzt rückwirkend überlege, was ich alles gemacht habe, um diesen Aufwand zu betreiben, das Spiel zu erleben, dann bin ich manchmal selber erstaunt. Also diesen Kontakt, den ich damals nach diesem ersten Olympiastadionbesuch hatte, den habe ich dann weiter genutzt, also jetzt nicht dieses Mädel, sondern den Fan. Und ich bin, das müsst ihr euch mal vorstellen, als fast, also meistens fast einzige Frau mit diesem Fanclub, mit dem Bus und diesen saufenden Typen losgefahren. Das muss man sich echt mal geben. Ja, aber ich selber habe halt nicht getrunken. Ja nicht, ja klar. Also ich trinke schon, aber ich bin eben keine Biertrinkerin. Ich war es damals auch nicht und war aber ja darauf angewiesen und musste ja auch irgendwie gucken. Also ich hatte das Glück, dass ein Typ dabei war, der Mirko aus Kassel, den habe ich da halt im Fanclub kennengelernt. Der wohnte bei mir in der Nähe, der hat mich auch immer abgeholt, um mit mir dann eben zu dieser, wo der Bus halt losfuhr, da gemeinsam hinzugehen. Der hat nicht die ganze Zeit neben mir gesessen, weil der ist dann auch hinten und hat damit seinen Jungs, seinen Jim Beam und keine Ahnung was gesoffen, aber ich konnte mich auf den 100 Prozent verlassen, so. Aber ich habe da oft so gesessen und gedacht, meine Güte, was tust du dir an? Laute Musik den ganzen Tag, die ganze Fahrt, auch oft Musik, die ich selber gar nicht gehört habe und dann eben, ja, diese vielen, nicht immer nur tollen Typen, die dann eben dabei waren und Alkohol verändert ja so. Doch, aber ich habe dann immer jemanden gehabt, der mit mir dann im Stadion war und ja, da kannst du dann nicht sagen, geschult oder so, sondern ich habe dann eben nachgefragt und der hat das gemacht, so gut er konnte. Und natürlich habe ich sicherlich viele Spieldetails, also richtige Verortungen des Balles und was auch immer, nicht mitbekommen. Aber ich habe genug mitbekommen, um ja im Nachhinein damit Leuten über das Spiel zu diskutieren oder eben in den Fernsehzusammenschnitten das auch wiederzufinden.
Wenn ich mir überlege, dass man mich zwingen würde, du darfst weiter Fußballfan sein, aber du musst auswärts fahren und du siehst nichts. Du musst einfach nur der Musik und den Gesprächen zuhören und du darfst die Fahnen der Leute riechen. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich noch Fußballfan wäre. Du hast wirklich viel auf dich genommen.
Ja, aber und trotzdem, also das sind dann einfach auch so Erlebnisse, die, sowas vergisst du auch nicht. Das sind einfach tolle Sachen und ich weiß gar nicht, also was halt toll war jetzt bei den Bayern-Amateuren, um da nochmal drauf zu sprechen zu kommen, die haben ja in der Regionalliga, also zu den Bayern-Amateuren bin ich gegangen, weil Pflügler da ja seine Karriere fortgesetzt hat. Also Hans Pflügler ist nach seinem Ende der Karriere zum Amateuren gewechselt und da dachte ich, ja mach mal, geh da mal auch hin und in Kassel studiert. Regionalliga gab es Mannschaften in Hessen, Egelsbach, Eintracht-Amateure, Hessen-Kassel. Zu diesen Spielen bin ich dann gegangen mit auch wieder einer Begleitperson. Und das hatte dann den Charme, kleine Stadien, ganz wenige Fans, interessante Fans. Also ich finde, fand die Bayern-Amateure damals, das war großartig, was die so für Ideen hatten und Support gemacht haben. Und ich bin das erste Mal dann auch mit dem Thema Fanszene zusammen gestoßen. Ich habe da einen Typen kennengelernt, Nico hieß der, der hat damals so eine Fanszene gemacht und auch solche Sachen, diese Geschichten von Ground Hopping und so was da halt reingeschrieben. Das sind ja auch so Sachen, da weiß ja oft Autonormal-Fußball-Fan gar nicht, was sowas ist. Mit sowas bin ich, also mit diesen Leuten bin ich auch in Kontakt gekommen. Das ist auch ganz, ganz toll. Und, und jetzt kommen wir zu der anderen Geschichte, die für mich natürlich auch spannend war, diese kleinen Stadien boten die Möglichkeit, Autogramme zu holen. Und für mich auch die Möglichkeit, also ja, so ein Spieler dann tatsächlich auch mal direkt, ja, bei mir oder im Gespräch sozusagen zu haben. Also ich sag mal, der Sehende hat ja die Möglichkeit, zumindest Leute zu sehen und Bilder zu sehen und in der Masse dann vielleicht auch eher nochmal an irgendeinem Zaun hinzugehen, sich abklatschen zu lassen und dann auch zu wissen, wer einen abklatscht. Für mich war es total toll bei den Amateuren dann da Autogramme zu holen, einen Hansi Flügler mal zu erleben. Ich habe da Leute gesehen, die dann später Profis wurden – Gospo Darek, Semmi Kufur, Alex Zickler. Es war schon großartig. Und dann eben auch die zwei Spieler, über die ich dann meine zehnjährige Hachingzeit erlebt habe, die auch ganz, ganz besonders war. Das waren Matthias Zimmermann und Tobias Hager. Die sind von den Bayern Amateuren zu Haching gewechselt und ich bin mitgewechselt. Ich bin zwischen 1996 und 2008 oder 2010 sagen wir mal, bis dann das unrühmliche Ende kam, ein glühender Haching-Fan gewesen. Und das gehört auch zu meinem Fußball. Da sei auch noch in anderen Bereichen, weil du so gefragt hast, was ich eben auch spannend finde. Ich finde so diese kleinen Vereine, die dann irgendwas auf die Beine stellen, ganz überraschend und ganz anders. Also jetzt wie in der ersten Liga Darmstadt zum Beispiel. Sowas finde ich einfach großartig und das habe ich mit Haching einfach ganz, ganz toll erlebt. Oder eben auch die Bayern-Amateure, die dann zum Beispiel gegen Stuttgart im Elfmeterschießen gewonnen haben, gegen VfB im Pokal. Da war ich zwar live nicht dabei, aber zumindest am Radio und das sind einfach, das sind tolle Sachen. Und bei Haching im Prinzip ja seit 96 das miterlebt zu haben, nicht erst in der Bundesliga-Saison zu denen zu stoßen, sondern vorher schon, bot mir ja auch die Möglichkeit, ich sag mal, wenn wir auswärts irgendwie 20, 30 Leute waren, war das ja viel. Da habe ich auch viele tolle Kontakte zu Fans gehabt und habe eben auch ganz viele Spieler und auch Vereinsfunktionäre eben ja kennenlernen dürfen. Und den Aufstieg mit zu erleben und dann, ich sag euch, die schönsten Erlebnisse mit waren wirklich der erste Auswärtssieg in Stuttgart, ich war dabei, der zweite Auswärtssieg in Dortmund, ich war dabei und das Spiel, wo Bayern durch Hachingmeister wurde, war ich im Sportpark und das war sensationell. Das war so klasse. Ja großartig, das nimmt dir keiner. Gegen Leverkusen, das Baller-Spiel. Ja, ich war da als Haching-Fan und es war schon toll, wenn dann die Bayern-Fans kommen und sich vor einen knien und sich bedanken und so, das hatte was. Und es war das erste Mal, dass ich trotz meiner guten Kontakte keine Karten im Haching-Block gekriegt habe bei dem Spiel. Also ich musste wirklich auf die gegenüber in den Block Nordkurve, wo auch die Leverkusener standen. Also es war interessant. In Haching ist ja so, man kommt ja kurz vor dem Spiel und ist da in seinem Biergarten und geht erst ins Stadion kurz bevor der Anpfiff kommt. Und im Biergarten, es war alles voller Leverkusener. Und ich dachte nur, ach du Levergott, jetzt muss ich erleben, wie Daumenmeister wird und will ich das wirklich. Und die sagten schon, bitte in Unentschieden und so. Und wir standen im Steeblock und hatten vor uns ein, der Radio dabei hatte und wo wir dann halt mitkriegten, was im Olympiastadion los war. Ja und dann einfach zu sehen. Also ich ärgere mich noch heute und komme immer wieder mit anderen in Diskussion, die dann anfangen, ja blöde Haching und hat Leverkusen die Meisterschaft versaut. Und wo ich echt immer nur sagen kann, wie kann man taktisch so blöd sein? Also Haching kann kein Spiel machen. Also man hätte sich als Leverkusen echt nur hinten rein stellen müssen. Man hätte nur das 0-0 über die Zeit bringen müssen. Haching hätte nichts gemacht und was macht Leverkusen? Wir machen hier einen auf schön, schön spielen und laden Haching zum Kontern ein. Da kann ich nur sagen, selber schuld. Und das hat überhaupt nichts damit zu tun. Als Haching, denen die Meisterschaft versaut haben, das haben sie selbst.
Gut, ging natürlich auch schlecht los mit einem mit einem Eigentor ab. Aber das ist ja Fußballgeschichte. Wie ist denn das? Ich könnte mir vorstellen, wenn du jetzt zum Autogrammjagen gehst, dann geht es dir ja, wie du schon gesagt hast, nicht um das Autogramm, sondern eher um das Treffen mit dem Spieler. Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass das eine Situation ist, auf die viele Spiele unvorbereitet sind, wo man dann recht schnell merkt, wie die so drauf sind.
Richtig.
Was sind da so für Situationen entstanden? Kommen daher dann auch dein Fable für gewisse Spieler, dass sie sich da besonders gut verhalten haben. Wie sind die so drauf?
Also das Lustige ist ja nochmal, wenn ich bei den Bayern-Ambiteuren mit irgendeiner Begleitung bin, die wissen dann ja oft gar nicht, was das für ein Spieler ist. Selbst wenn sie den auf dem Spielfeld erkannt haben, vielleicht kennt ihr das auch, dass manche Leute dann, wenn sie dann geduscht sind und so anders aussehen. Also die sind nicht immer gleich so zuzuordnen. Also vor allem die halt nicht so bekannten. Na ja, und dann habe ich gerade ganz oft zu dem gesagt, möchte zwar ein Autogramm von dir haben, aber wer bist du? Ich meine, das ist ja schon mal ein bisschen blöd, ne?
Das ist ein guter Einstieg.
Nebensatz immer gleich gesagt, sorry, ich kenne dich natürlich vom Spielen her, aber ich bin blind. Das habe ich natürlich dann immer sofort gesagt, aber es gab mal eine Situation, da habe ich auch einen Spieler angesprochen und dann habe ich so gefragt, wer bist du? Und dann sagte er so Marco. Und dann sagte ich so Marco Grimm und er so, ja Marco Grimm. Also hast du richtig gemerkt, dass er ein bisschen genervt war? Und dann habe ich es eben auch gleich erklärt. Ja, wie soll ich sagen, die waren ja unterschiedlich.
Also dich interessiert ja die Psychologie, das hast du ja gesagt, und offensichtlich ja auch Persönlichkeiten, wenn du ja für Spieler sogar den Verein wächst, das finde ich total interessant, weil das ja wirklich eine Art ist, den Fußball anders zu erleben.
Wobei das dann natürlich oft auch Situationen waren, wenn ich die Spieler dann halt länger auch höre in Interviews oder so. Also das ist jetzt nicht nur die persönliche Begegnung. Aber klar, bei der persönlichen Begegnung ist es schon so, ja, da gab es natürlich unterschiedliche, aber diese Begegnungen waren ja meistens nur kurz. Ich sag mal, bei Haring gab es schon so Situationen, wenn man dann irgendwie vor dem Spiel schon Leute mal getroffen hat, hallo gesagt hat. Da gibt es eben Leute, die eher so, wo du so das Gefühl hast, die sind so arrogant oder haben eh keine Zeit oder keinen Bock. Und dann gab es eben Leute, die zumindest den Eindruck vermitteln, dass sie einfach vom Typ her höflich, sympathisch und so nett einfach sind. Also es gab eine Situation, die kann ich ja mal erzählen. Da standen wir am Zaun nach einem Haring-Spiel. Die Spieler waren sozusagen auf dem Weg Richtung Kabine. Und ich wollte ein Autogramm von Matthias Lust haben, weil Matthias Lust ist damals ja mit Haring aufgestiegen und hat ja dummerweise den Vertrag in Bochum zu früh unterschrieben musste, also sozusagen mit Bochum in der Zweitliga spielen. Und seine Kollegen haben die zwei Jahre Erstliga durchlebt. Und er kam zurück und ich fand halt, er gehörte damals für mich zu dieser Aufstiegsmannschaft dazu. Und ich wollte auf der einen Seite ein Autogramm von ihm haben. Ich glaube noch irgendwie so auf so ein, weiß nicht, ob es ein Haring-Poster oder T-Shirt oder sowas war. Und dann hatte ich noch ein Foto, das ich unterschreiben lassen wollte. Und ich war dann irgendwie relativ hektisch so, weil ich dachte, der muss jetzt bestimmt sofort fortgehen und ich muss jetzt irgendwie zusehen, dass ich jetzt schnell dieses Foto da aus dem Rucksack rausholen soll. Und dann hat er irgendwie gesagt, lass dir Zeit. Also ich weiß nicht mehr genau den Wortlaut, aber das war einfach ein ganz, ganz tolles Gefühl, dass da jemand irgendwie mir vermittelt hat, das ist jetzt völlig in Ordnung, dass das jetzt ein bisschen dauert, ich bleibe jetzt hier stehen. Das ist kein Problem. So und das hat mich natürlich, also da hat er einfach ganz, ganz viele Pluspunkte natürlich bei mir bekommen. So in der Situation.
Das glaube ich. Und wie ist das mit den Spielern heute? Weil wenn ich mir so die O-Töne angucke, die man nach dem Spiel und eigentlich auch vor dem Spiel bekommt, dann ist es ja immer dieselbe Soße, wird ja oft genug auch beklagt und es gibt ganz, ganz wenige Interviews nur noch, wo ich jetzt den Eindruck hätte, ich bekomme jetzt tatsächlich mal einen Einblick in die Persönlichkeit dieses Spielers.
Richtig. Das geht mir ganz genauso. Also heute hat man, man sagt ja immer, es sind irgendwie kaum noch Typen da.
Heute soll das rankommen, Schwede, oder?
Ja, ja klar. Ich bin ja jetzt auch nicht mehr bei Haring und ich bin auch nicht mehr bei den Bayern-Amateuren. Was heute ist, das wäre dann vielleicht noch so das zweite Thema, heute kriege ich eigentlich eher dann mal einen längeren Kontakt zu irgendeiner Persönlichkeit aus dem Fußball, wenn wir über den Fan-Club Seehunde irgendwelche Gäste haben. Also da gab es halt, wir machen den Fan-Club, gibt es ja seit 92, habe ich gesagt, und wir machen jährliche Fan-Club-Treffen und da hat es immer auch Vorträge und Gespräche mit Persönlichkeiten aus dem Fußball, aus den Vereinen, wo wir unser Jahrestreff gemacht haben, immer gegeben und da habe ich natürlich dann ein bisschen mehr mitgekriegt. Jetzt ist es so bei Interviews, ich denke schon, dass man ein Stück weit schon ein bisschen, ich würde nicht sagen die Persönlichkeit, aber selbst wenn sie immer nur ihre selben Statements abgeben, kriegt man ja schon so ein bisschen mit, wie geben sie ab? Sind sie wirklich professionell oder sind sie genervt und trotz dieser teilweise sehr gleichen Statements geht euch ja sicherlich genauso, habt ihr trotzdem unterschiedliche Eindrücke von Spielern, die ihr eben sympathisch findet oder eher nicht. Und so geht es mir natürlich auch. Und da haben sich auch Sachen verändert. Also ich kann mal so ein Beispiel sagen, Oliver Kahn. Also ich habe mich damals, als es klar war, er kommt zu Bayern, habe ich mich ziemlich drüber geärgert, weil ich damals die Hoffnung hatte, dass Gospo Darik irgendwie seinen Weg gehen kann. Also als Nachfolger dann von Auman. Ich wollte Kahn überhaupt nicht haben erst. Und ja, am Schluss war er einer von meinen Lieblingsspielern bei Bayern. Und zwar deswegen, nicht nur, weil er einfach grandiose Leistung gebracht hat, und weil mich das immer beeindruckt hat. Sein, ja, alles fürgeben und seine Interviews, wo man immer so sagt, er ist arrogant und was auch immer. Da fand ich halt immer, ich habe das so interpretiert, das war seine Art, sich auch zu schützen vor Angriffen. Dann bin ich halt arrogant. Und was mich eben an ihm beeindruckt hat, im Gegensatz jetzt zu Michael Ballack, zumindest war mein Eindruck immer so, kann es wirklich als Kapitän immer zu Interviews gekommen, auch wenn es blöd gelaufen ist. Also er war eigentlich immer da. Und das fand ich gut und das habe ich bei anderen Spielern eben nicht so empfunden.
Jetzt hast du schon die Seehunde angesprochen und hast gesagt, 1992 habt ihr euch gegründet. Magst du uns mal kurz erzählen, was sich da handelt und wie das eigentlich auch kam?
Ja, fange ich erstmal davon an, um was es sich handelt. Also jetzt sind wir der Fanclub Seehundefußball Fanclub für Blinde und Sehbehinderte. Vereinsübergreifend, das haben wir ja schon gesagt. Wir vertreten die Interessen Blinder und Sehbehinderte Stadionbesucher. Also wir setzen uns dafür ein. Wir haben uns in den letzten Jahren ganz stark eben für die Kopfhörerplätze in den Stadien eingesetzt. Wir setzen uns dafür ein, dass auch die Wege zu den Stadien, also ja, dass sie einfach möglichst barrierefrei sind. Also dass man irgendwie eine gute Situation hat, ins Stadion zu kommen. Wir möchten die Begegnung zwischen blinden und sehenden Fußballfans initiieren und wollen so unsere Belange und das es uns überhaupt gibt, in die Öffentlichkeit tragen. Auch in dem Kontakt mit den Vereinen, also dass Vereinen auch bewusst wird, es gibt blinde, aber auch anders behinderte Fans und auch die haben bestimmte Ansprüche an Plätze, an Sicherheit im Stadion, was auch immer. Für blinde Fans versuchen wir, für blinde und sehbehinderte Fans natürlich den Austausch zu ermöglichen, Informationen zu ermöglichen. Wir haben also einmal eine interne Mailingliste, wo wir uns gegenseitig Tipps geben. Die Leute sind ja in unterschiedlichen Stadionen unterwegs, dann kann man mal fragen, du warst doch schon in Dortmund, wie machen wir das am besten vom Bahnhof dahin? Wir geben ein Audiomagazin raus, also eine CD mit eigenen Beiträgen, um die blinden Fußballfans, die jetzt vielleicht auch nicht unterwegs sind, gut zu informieren über alles, über unseren Fanclub intern, aber natürlich auch über das Fußballgeschehen. Und wir führen eben einmal im Jahr, also müssen wir das ja sowieso wegen der Mitgliederversammlung, aber wir führen einmal im Jahr eigentlich ein Fanclub-Treffen durch. Die Anfänge waren so, unsere Fanclub-Leitung, die zwei Damen, die sind auch immer noch im Vorstand – Nina Schweppe und Regina Hillmann – die beiden haben damals Interviews für Schülerzeitungen gemacht und waren Köln- und Bremen-Fans und hatten ein Interview mit Christoph Daum geführt und haben sich dann überlegt, jetzt wollen wir mal ein Interview mit Heinkiss führen, mit den Bayern, aber da kriegen wir bestimmt keinen, sie sind sowieso zu arrogant. Na ja, und sie kriegten ihr Interview und sie kriegt nicht nur ein Interview, sondern einfach auch einen guten, persönlichen Kontakt zu Jupp Heinkiss und zu einem Mitarbeiter bei Bayern München und dieser Mitarbeiter hat dann den beiden empfohlen, ja, wollt ihr denn, dass die Möglichkeit, die ihr habt, nicht auch anderen Blinden zugänglich machen, also mal so Interviews mit Spielern und so, das könnten wir doch hier engagieren und so haben die sich dann, haben die einen Bayern-Fan-Club erstmal gegründet. Ich habe davon erfahren, es gibt Zeitungen in, es gibt zu Zeitschriften in Blindenschrift, und in einer dieser Zeitschriften war eine Anzeige, ja, Bayern-Fans gesucht, wir wollen Fan-Club gründen. Ich war glaube ich erstes Mitglied. Ich habe mich gleich an die beiden, die haben in Hamburg gewohnt oder wohnen in Hamburg, ich habe mich gleich telefonisch an die gewandt und ja, das war so 91 und 92 im Oktober, übrigens auch noch an meinem Geburtstag, ich darf es ja jetzt mal sagen, haben wir unser erstes Fan-Club-Treffen in München gehabt und das ist auch was, ja.
Die Hamburger und aus Kassel oder Göttingen, Hannover und dann trifft man sich in München, ja.
Richtig, zum Fan-Club-Treffen bei den Bayern. Wir waren also in einem super Hotel untergebracht, also es ist oft so, dass diese Fan-Club-Treffen halt nur zustande kommen, irgendwie wenn man zu jemanden in einem Verein oder wo auch immer Kontakt hat und dann auch deren Möglichkeiten mit nutzen kann, sonst könnten wir das auch finanziell alles gar nicht so tragen. Also wir hatten dann das Glück, dass wir sozusagen in so einem Vertragshotel, wo halt die Bundesligisten dann auch unterkommen, dass wir dann, also das heißt, seit ich im Fan-Club Seehunde bin, habe ich dann auch etwas noblere Hotels und so was kennengelernt, das war vorher nicht so unbedingt meine Räumlichkeiten. Ja, also wir waren da in einem Hotel untergebracht, in der Nähe vom Bahnhof. Das war noch ein kurzes Fan-Club-Treffen von Samstagmorgen bis Sonntagnachmittag. Jetzt sind sie immer von Freitags bis Sonntags. Und bei diesem Fan-Club-Treffen, wir waren wirklich nur eine kleine Gruppe, ich glaube einschließlich begleitet Person sieben oder acht Leute. Richtig klein und schnuckelig. Wir haben Mittag gegessen im Stadion, im Olympiastadion, in dieser Opel, sag mal, Lounge dazu, also im Raum von Opel halt. Und wir hatten als Begleiter unter anderem von Bayern einen ehemaligen oder damals noch tätigen Ordner, ein Herr Müller. Der hat mich und meine damalige Freundin begleitet den ganzen Tag. Das war natürlich toll, weil der konnte ja noch mal ganz andere Sachen erzählen, was ich denen alles fragen konnte. Ja und dann haben wir also Mittag gegessen und hatten dann eine Stadionführung. Das war also beziehungsweise nicht Stadionführung, also wir waren in den Kabinen. Ich habe auf dem Rasen des Olympiastadions gestanden. Das war unglaublich. Also es war ohne Worte. Dann kam das Spiel. Jetzt wollen wir mal gucken, ob ihr fit seid. Bayern München, Werder Bremen, 24.10.1992.
Nein, ich weiß nicht.
Es war eine Niederlage. Eine 1 zu 3 Niederlage.
Deswegen habe ich mich nicht mehr dran erinnert.
Aber man hatte mir dann doch ein tolles Geburtstagstückgeschenk gemacht. Nämlich eine Viertelstunde vor Spielende kam Hansi Pflügler, um mir zu gratulieren. Und dann waren wir abends noch essen und da war dann noch Bruno Labbadia als Gast. Da habe ich also das erste Mal Labbadia kennengelernt und mit ihm gesprochen. Er war noch häufiger zu Gast bei uns. Also wir haben ihn in der Zeit noch häufiger gesehen. Ja und am Sonntagmorgen das letzte Highlight. Wir waren in dem großen Konferenzraum in der Säbener Straße im Geschäftszimmer. Und jeder durfte ein Polaroid-Bild mit der Schale machen. Also ich hatte sozusagen die Meisterschale in der Hand.
Und das alles hört sich jetzt fantastisch an und spricht ja auch dafür, dass wenn man die richtigen Leute bei den Vereinen kannte, dann sind die einem da auch sehr offen und großzügig begegnet.
Es waren die ersten drei Jahre in München und die Fanclub-Leitung ist auch sehr personenbezogen. Und entsprechend haben die ihre Vereine häufiger gewechselt. Jetzt sind sie ganz enthusiastische Köln-Fans und sind da auch in der Köln-Szene sehr aktiv. Sind da auch mit den Fanbussen und Ultras und so was unterwegs. Also das, was ich in den 90er Jahren gemacht habe, machen die beiden jetzt. Und dadurch hat sich das zum einen dahin bewegt, dass wir eben jetzt ein allgemeiner, also vereinsübergreifender Fanclub sind, aber wir haben dann eben einfach auch andere Vereine kennengelernt. Also wir waren in Hannover, wir waren in Dortmund, wir waren in Schalke, wir waren in Hamburg, wir waren in München, Gladbach, Leverkusen. Und jetzt nochmal diese Verbindung zu den Kopfhörerplätzen. Wir hatten unser Fanclub-Treffen 1999 in Leverkusen und wir hatten als Gast Kurt Fossen dort, der damals ja Abteilungsleiter im Fußballbereich Barbaia Leverkusen war. Ja, und der hatte in Manchester erlebt, dass es dort irgendwie dieses Angebot für Blinde gibt, diese Reportagen. Und hat uns davon erzählt und hat dann so gesagt, ja, was würdet ihr denn halten, wenn wir Barbaia Leverkusen das mal machen? Na ja, und dann haben wir gesagt, ja super. Aber ehrlich gesagt, als er weg war, haben wir gedacht, hm, lass ihn reden. Da wird eh nichts passieren, wie viele wollen irgendwie was machen und, ne. Wurde dann mal kurz geredet und es passiert nichts, aber es passierte. Und Leverkusen, das war 99. Also wir hatten das Fettstreffen im Frühjahr. Und das erste Spiel war Leverkusen-Ulm in der Saison 99 2000. Und eines der Spiele drauf, das im Dezember Leverkusen unter Haching, das war mein erstes Spiel, wo ich dann hingefahren bin mit den Kopfhörerplätzen. Und Leverkusen hatte das ganz toll organisiert. Die haben nämlich als Reporter, jetzt mal zum Thema Schulung und Anspruch, die haben als Reporter den E-Jugend-Trainer gehabt. Burak. Und das witzige ist, der hat das jahrelang gemacht. Und jetzt, wenn ihr ihn sehen wollt, müsst ihr euch den Mannschaftsarzt von Bayer Leverkusen anregen. Unser Reporter ist jetzt Mannschaftsarzt bei Bayer Leverkusen. Du könnt die Karriere gehen.
Ich wollte ja sagen, das ist mal eine Karriere. Das ist ein lustiger Umweg vom E-Jugend-Trainer über Live-Reportage zum Mannschaftsarzt.
Genau.
Gibt's wohl auch kein zweites Mal. Aber da hat das Ganze angefangen, 99. Ja. Wir haben im Vorgespräch schon ein bisschen zu diesem Thema uns unterhalten und du hast dann gesagt, die große Explosion, die große Verbreitung für dieses Ding gab es dann zur Webmeisterschaft im eigenen Land.
Vielleicht vorher noch mal kurz. Nach Leverkusen ging es dann los in Hamburg, beim HSV und bei St. Pauli. Und dann kamen weitere dazu, aber die Organisation war sehr unterschiedlich, wie die Vereine das gemacht haben. Also Leverkusen, den E-Jugend-Trainer, da sieht man ja irgendwie schon, okay, das wollen wir nicht einfach nur so irgendeinen Fan machen lassen, sondern das ist schon gut, wenn das jemand macht, der auch von Taktik und sowas Ahnung hat, finde ich, ist daran zu erkennen. In Hamburg war es ganz interessant, also St. Pauli hat es über ein sehr engagiertes Fanprojekt gemacht und der HSV – und jetzt kommen wir nämlich zum Thema Qualität – beim HSV ist es so, dass es dort einen Studiengang – ich glaube, Sportwissenschaften heißt der – gibt und einer der Dozenten, Bruder Jürgen Trede, der hat sozusagen das genutzt, Studenten, die eben so in dem Bereich Sportjournalismus und sowas wollten, sozusagen da die Praxis zu bieten. Also die haben – der hat sozusagen das ausgearbeitet als Dozent, was muss für so eine Reportage wichtig sein, wo unterscheidet sie sich auch zur klassischen Radioreportage, was müssen so Reporter im Stadion, die vor Ort berichten können, wie muss die Sprache sein, was müssen Leute mitbringen und die haben das wirklich so gemacht, dass sie – also er dabei war natürlich und dass sie dann diese Reportagen aufgezeichnet haben und tatsächlich dann im Studium, also als Studieninhalt dann auch besprochen haben. Und dadurch ging das dann auch los, dass so im Laufe der Jahre auch dieses Know-how ja sich verbreitet hat, verbreitet wurde und dann irgendwann, als das dann Schule machte, ich nehme an, das war dann so Richtung 2006 irgendwann, dass dann auch die DFL mit auf den Zug gesprungen ist und es jetzt einmal im Jahr auch so, also seit Jahren schon ein jährliches Reporter-Treffen auch gibt, wo die Leute auch geschult werden, sich austauschen.
Das ist dieses Seminar, über das ich auf der Seehunde-Homepage auch gelesen habe.
Genau, was im Januar war.
Genau, zum neunten Mal, glaube ich, stand da.
Ganz genau.
Wohl auch dann in Verbindung mit der WM oder eben im Nachgang zu WM.
Genau, und wichtig ist Bruder auch immer und den Machern war es auch immer, dass Nutzer auch mit einbezogen werden. Weil die natürlich letztlich das Feedback geben müssen.
Aber wenn ich das jetzt richtig verstanden habe, dann ist dieses Seminar auch, das es jetzt seit neun Jahren gibt, die einzige übergreifende Institution für das Ganze. Das heißt, jeder Verein kümmert sich oder eben das Fanprojekt vor Ort, dann selbst um seine Lösung. Es gibt da keinerlei zentrale Organisation dafür ansonsten, oder?
Nein, also sie haben jetzt so ein Kompetenzzentrum eingerichtet. Das ist noch nicht so lange. Das war ein ehemaliger Reporter von Leverkusen, der jetzt sozusagen dieses Kompetenzzentrum Blindenreportage so leitet. Aber ansonsten, es sind auch nicht immer die Fanprojekte. Also das ist ganz unterschiedlich, wie das in den einzelnen Vereinen gehandhabt wurde. Und um das nochmal mit der WM vorzuführen, irgendwann ging es natürlich auch darum, also wenn die WM schon in Deutschland ist, dann wäre es ja irgendwie nur recht und billig, wenn da natürlich Deutschland auch für blinde Fußballfans im Stadion Tickets anbietet mit diesem Reporter-Service. Und dann war das Voraussetzung, dass die WM-Stadien oder die Stadien, die eben WM-Stadien wurden, dass die Vereine das eben auch mit anbieten. Und einige Vereine, die sich eben vorher dafür nicht interessiert hatten oder auch geweigert hatten, die mussten dann halt. Und die haben es natürlich heute dann auch noch, zum Beispiel Kaiserslautern. Also Kaiserslautern war das so ein Ding, die hatten das vorher nicht. Und durch diese WM-Geschichte, ja, mussten sie und sind wahrscheinlich in der Richtung dann auch unterstützt worden. Das ist ja manchmal auch eine Frage, ja, was brauche ich und woher kriege ich dann die Anlage und so was alles. Mittlerweile ist es so, dass alle Erstliga-Stadien dieses Angebot haben, dass viele in der zweiten Liga und bis nach unten dritte Liga, teilweise auch weiter unten einzelne Vereine das anbieten. Und es ist heute auch nicht mehr so einfach, wie es noch in den ersten Jahren war, Karten zu bekommen.
Ja, viele…
Entschuldigung, wie viele Plätze gibt es denn da? Das würde mich noch interessieren. Also es sind ja Kopfhörerplätze und da sitzt jemand, der kommentiert. Und von welcher Menge reden wir da, auch wenn du sagst, es ist schwierig an Karten zu kommen?
Ja, das ist ganz unterschiedlich. Das handhaben auch die Vereine unterschiedlich. Also es gab Vereine, die haben… also ich kann mich erinnern, es gab mal… VfB Stuttgart hatte am Anfang nur fünf Plätze. Wie viele die jetzt haben, weiß ich nicht. Also beim HSV haben wir jetzt 30 Plätze, nachdem wir eine neue Anlage haben, die auch eine größere Reichweite fasst. In Köln sind es, glaube ich, auch 25 Plätze. In München weiß ich jetzt gar nicht genau, wie viele die haben.
Wir sind jetzt ohnehin ein bisschen quer in das ganze Thema eingestiegen. Vielleicht sollten wir das nochmal ein bisschen so zusammenfassend für die Zuhörer auch nochmal genauer darlegen, was ist denn so eine blinden Reportage im Stadion? Wie kann man sich das vorstellen? Wir haben gerade gesagt, es gibt Kopfhörerplätze. Das heißt, man kriegt eine Karte dafür. Du hast jetzt auch gerade gesagt, das ist unterschiedlich. Gehen wir mal davon aus, man hat jetzt eine Karte und kommt ins Stadion, da gibt es die Plätze. Da setzt man sich ran, da ist neben dem Stuhl einfach ein Kopfhörerstecker und man steckt den mitgebrachten Kopfhörer ein oder wie läuft das?
Das ist in Leverkusen auch so. Die haben das mit den Buchsen und den Kopfhörern. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob sie es jetzt nach Verlegung der Plätze immer noch haben, aber vorletzte Saison war es noch so. Die anderen Stadien machen das mit diesen Funkempfängern. Also es ist so, dass man, wenn man auf dem Platz sitzt, dann irgendwann so kurz vor 15-20 Minuten vor Spielbeginn kommt dann einer rum, entweder die Reporter oder eben irgendwelche anderen Helfer von dem Verein und verteilen die Kopfhörer. In manchen Stadien muss man sich das auch abholen, also Kopfhörer und Empfänger. Und das funktioniert mit Funktechnik, also nicht mit Kabel. Kabel ist wie gesagt nur in Leverkusen, ansonsten hat man eben Kopfhörer und so einen Empfänger, den man sich um den Hals hängen kann und wo man auch die Lautstärke verändern kann. Und da ist dann eben auf einem bestimmten Kanal, empfängt man das dann halt, der eben voreingestellt ist.
Wir haben im Vorfeld kurz einen Clip gehört, der auf einer Website zur Verfügung gestellt wurde, den wir glaube ich dann auch in den Show Notes verlinken. Das hört sich im Grunde, was man da hört, an wie eine normale Radioreportage, oder? Natürlich mit schwankender Qualität, abhängig vom Kommentator, vom Reporter. Aber im Grunde klingt das sehr ähnlich.
Ja, es klingt sehr ähnlich und für den Ausschnitt mag das auch stimmig sein. Aber der Radioreporter kann zwischendurch irgendwelche Geschichten erzählen, was er auch tut. Also ich fehl dir mal 90 Minuten Champions League mit zwei Reportern. Das ist nicht immer nur gut. Der Unterschied ist, du musst im Stadion absolut auf Ballhöhe bleiben. Du hast überhaupt keine Zeit, dich mit den Klamotten von Pep Guardiola zu beschäftigen oder mit einer Zusammenfassung von dem gerade Gesehenen, wenn wieder was auf dem Platz passiert. Weil im Stadion höre ich die Zuschauerreaktion, ich weiß sofort, dass was passiert. Und Anspruch ist wirklich, du musst das schildern, was der Sehende auch sieht. Das heißt, wichtig ist, wer hat den Ball und vor allem, wo ist er auch. Verortung ist so ein Schlagwort. Rechts am Strafraum und zieht jetzt rüber auf die linke Seite und da nimmt wer auch immer den Ball.
Also es ist noch ein bisschen mehr detailliert, das Geschehen auf dem Platz und nicht so sehr nur das Spielgeschehen, wie es bei einer Radioreportage ist.
Ja und vor allem auch, du musst auch reagieren, wenn plötzlich irgendwas ist, was die Zuschauer, also ich weiß nicht, wenn jetzt irgendwas in der Kurve oder sowas passiert. Also das erzählt der Radioreporter halt im Nachgang, aber du musst es in dem Moment, weil in dem Moment sieht man es ja. Ich muss wissen, was da passiert.
Um die Verknüpfung zum Gehörten direkt herzustellen.
Das heißt aber quasi, dass eine Radioreportage, die man ja zum Beispiel bei Sport 1 FM kann man ja jetzt auch Vollreportagen hören zu jedem Spiel, das ist ja einer der Gründe, warum es im Radio nicht mehr über 90 Minuten lang live gibt, das ist eine rechte Frage. Das ist quasi ein Plan B, aber das hat einfach nicht denselben Wert für jemanden, der das Spiel als Blinder erfahren möchte.
Ja, und ich merke auch, ich bin anspruchsvoller geworden, seit ich die guten Reporter im Stadion erlebe. Also gerade, wo du sagst, Sport 1, letztes Wochenende bin ich bald ausgeflippt, als ich hier ein Spiel gehört habe. Ich weiß jetzt, dass genau bei dem Dortmund-Bayerenspiel die erste Halbzeit war ja wirklich rassig und von irgendwie 1. bis 45. Minute war es wirklich auch eine tolle Reportage von dem Christian, keine Ahnung, was wie er hieß. In der zweiten Halbzeit gab es um die 50. 55. Minute eine Situation, da hat er 1000 andere Sachen erzählt. Ich hörte am Publikum, dass eigentlich auf dem Platz was passierte, aber er war nicht am Ball. Ich bin bald abgedreht, ich denke, was soll das denn, was interessiert denn, was letzte Woche vor zwei Jahren oder sonst was war? Der war einfach nicht auf Ballhöhe, obwohl was passiert ist.
Das heißt, eine Blindenreportage muss wesentlich deskriptiver sein und es geht auch weniger darum, rhetorische Stielblüten erwachsen zu lassen und Nebenschauplätze aufzumachen, sondern ganz destriptiv. Wo ist der Ball, was machen die Fans, was ist auf dem Spielfeld zu erkennen und das dann 90 Minuten?
Genau, und die wechseln sich auch ab, weil das kann einer nicht, die sind zu zweit. Und natürlich, wenn auch eine Verletzten-Situation – also ich habe jetzt ganz oft durch diese blinden Reportage und einfach auch viel mehr einen Einblick, was da jetzt gerade passiert, wenn da einer behandelt wird. Weil Radio oder Fernsehen oder so wird das ja nicht beschrieben. Man sieht es ja im Fernsehen und der Radioreporter sagt einfach, gut, das ist jetzt eine Unterbrechung. Klar, wenn du ein langweiliges Ballgeschiebe hast oder wenn irgendwie gar nichts passiert, dann hat ja auch der Reporter im Stadion mal die Möglichkeit, noch mal was zur Taktik zu sagen oder noch mal eine Szene zusammenzufassen. Aber dann muss er sagen, warum er jetzt gerade das machen kann. Also dann gibt es wirklich diesen Hinweis, es passiert jetzt wirklich nichts, deswegen kann ich gerade mal. Und was auch wichtig ist, ich meine, die Reporter lernen ja auch immer dazu und man ist ja auch nicht jeden Tag gleich gut. Deswegen sind sie ja auch immer so froh, wenn es dann Feedback gibt. Ich habe das jetzt beim Spiel HSV Gladbach erlebt. Da waren die Reporter am Anfang so ein bisschen im Stress, weil irgendwas mit Empfänger nicht in Ordnung war. Und dann sind sie relativ schnell so in dieses Spiel eingestiegen. Und was sie wirklich vergessen haben, und das habe ich dann in der Halbzeitpause gleich angemahnt, die haben nicht gesagt, von welcher Seite wer spielt. Und das brauche ich um im Kopf. Also ich möchte wissen, spielt Gladbach jetzt von links nach rechts auf die HSV-Kurve oder umgekehrt. Das haben die einfach vergessen. Aber das ist auch wichtig, so etwas zu sagen.
Damit dein Bild im Kopf quasi komplett ist.
Ja, und dich auch in die richtige Richtung gucken. Ich drehe auch dann mal meinen Kopf und bin dabei. Oder eine Situation, da ist der Reporter beim 3 zu 2. Also Gladbach hat ja kurz vor Schluss noch den Anschlusstreffer geschossen. Ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen, ich habe in dem Moment erst mal gar nicht richtig gemerkt, dass da jetzt ein Tor gefallen ist, weil er mit der Stimme überhaupt nicht. Er hat das so, ja, so Tor. Und erst anhand der Gladbach-Reaktion und als der Stadionsprecher das dann gesagt hat, war mir wirklich klar, da ist ein Tor gefallen und das geht natürlich auch nicht. Also selbst wenn die Mannschaft dann verloren hat oder so, aber du kannst dich ja irgendwie nicht fünf Minuten später freuen. Andererseits gibt es natürlich auch lustige Situationen. Das war dann auch ein bisschen blöd gelaufen. Da war ich bei Wolfsburg gegen Bayern und dann hat Bayern ein Tor geschossen. Es war aber leider ein Abseitstor und ich war die Einzige, die da rumsprang und jubelte, weil der Reporter etwas länger braucht, um zu sagen, das war Abseits. Auch ein bisschen doof.
Ein bisschen ist gut. Wir haben im Vorgespräch auch kurz drüber gesprochen. Ich habe vor einigen Jahren mal einen Podcast gehört zu dem Thema Stadion, Blindenreportage im Stadion. Ich bringe leider nicht mehr zusammen, welcher es war und habe es auch im Vorfeld nicht geschafft, das zu recherchieren. Ich werde es noch weiter versuchen und das dann in den Shownotes ergänzen, wenn ich es herausgefunden habe. Allerdings kann ich mich erinnern, dass es damals um die Angebote in Hamburg ging und ich glaube, um beide, sowohl den HSV als auch um St. Pauli. Und ich meine, dass einer der beiden – und ich glaube, mich zu erinnern, dass es St. Pauli war – diese Reportagen teilweise auch im Netz anbietet hinterher. Gibt es solche Angebote generell? Machen das mehrere Clubs oder mehrere Stadionsender, das dann hinterher anzubieten? Das wäre mit Sicherheit auch mal für den einen oder anderen Hörer interessanter, mal reinzuhören.
Ich weiß es nur von St. Pauli. Da gab es am Anfang auch große Diskussionen, weil die Leute so ein bisschen Angst hatten, wenn sie das jetzt tatsächlich wieder für eine Gruppe von draußen auch machen, also jetzt quasi für Netz. Vergessen sie dann nicht, dass es wirklich darum geht, dann wirklich das tatsächlich für die Leute zu tun, die eben im Stadion sind, also für die Blinden. Es war so ein bisschen Angst, ob man dann wieder so in die Gefahr gerät, dass man doch von diesen Nebenschauplätzen und sowas dann erzählt, weil es eben für die Fans draußen ist. Aber das hat Pauli wohl ganz gut hingekriegt. Ich habe jetzt keine Beschwerden darüber gehört, dass die Reportage sich verändert hat. Kann ich mir bei dem Reporter auch nicht vorstellen, weil er das wirklich lebt.
Ist es aber tatsächlich nichts, was auf breiter Ebene angeboten wird?
Nein, also in Österreich ist es so. Die machen ja ein ganz anderes Konzept. Die haben ja sozusagen die Reportage im Stadion. Die Reporter im Stadion, die also die Stadionreportage machen, gleichzeitig auch den Fernsehbildschirm haben. Und das, was die sozusagen reportieren, kommt auf die Kopfhörerplätze im Stadion, aber auch gleichzeitig ins Radio in Österreich und eben für die Audiodeskriptionen bei der Fernsehübertragung von den Spielen. Das ist eine Geschichte, das läuft da wohl ganz gut. Ich kann es mir gar nicht vorstellen, weil es für mich drei völlig verschiedene Zielgruppen sind. Ja, und eben wirklich auch Stadion und Radio. Es ist nicht dasselbe.
Wahrscheinlich würde die Deskription noch eher mit Stadion zusammenpassen als die Radioreportage.
Ja, auch dich, weil du im Stadion ja manchmal Sachen siehst, die die Kamera gar nicht einfach einfängt. Wir haben im Moment die ersten Versuche. Es gibt ja jetzt die NDR-Spiele, also im Dritten die Regionalligaspiele mit norddeutscher Beteiligung, die der Norddeutsche Rundfunk überträgt. Die sind seit dieser Saison mit einer wirklichen Audiodeskription und das haben jetzt auch schon ein paar Mal Reporter aus unseren Stadien gemacht und für die ist das schon eine ganz schöne Umstellung, sozusagen die Reportage zu machen, nur vom Fernsehbild. Weil, ihr könnt das ja mal selber euch dran erinnern, was teilweise ja manchmal von der Kamera eingeblendet wird. Dann hast du ja wirklich nicht mehr das Spiel geschehen, sondern tatsächlich irgendwie eben nur Pep Guardiola oder was auch immer im Bild. Oder eben den auf der Tribüne sitzenden Pinguinen.
Okay, aber dann habe ich jetzt eine Vorstellung, wie es jetzt im Best-Case in einem Stadion aussieht und vielleicht könnte es ja auch in Zukunft die Veränderung geben. Es gibt ja jetzt in vielen Bundesligastadien schon WLAN. Meiner Meinung nach müsste es ja eigentlich auch gehen, das von diesen Reporterplätzen zu lösen, über die Apps, die die Vereine haben. Zum Beispiel, die Bayern haben eine eigene App, wo ich eigene Inhalte im Stadion WLAN sehen kann, Livestreams und so weiter. Eigentlich müsste man da mal den Impuls setzen, könnte da nicht auch die Blindenreportage hin streamen, dann ist es nämlich nicht mehr an ein Ticket-Kontingent gebunden, ob ich das verfolgen kann als Sehbehinderter. Wäre jetzt so mein erster Gedanke gewesen. Also das ist die Stadionsituation.
Wäre wahrscheinlich auch technisch eine Herausforderung wegen Zeitversatz. Das normale Streaming hat ja gerne das Latenzproblem. Das müsste man dann natürlich irgendwie so speziell lösen, dass da möglichst nicht mehr als eine halbe Sekunde oder Sekunde Versatz vorhanden ist.
Da hast du recht, ja. Okay, lassen wir diesen Einfall von mir, der dann doch nicht so glorreich war, wie ich dachte, lassen wir den mal hinten an. Aber das ist die Stadionsituation, das kann ich mir jetzt sehr gut vorstellen in so einem Best-Case-Szenario. Aber jetzt kannst du ja nicht immer in Stadion fahren. Man hat ja leider auch noch andere Dinge zu tun. Wie ist es denn? Geben dir Radio-Reportaten etwas oder auch Sport 1 FM? Ist das dann ein gutes Metadon, was den Stadionbesuch ersetzt? Oder wie konsumierst du von zu Hause aus Fußball am liebsten?
Ja, eigentlich schon so. Also Radio und wenn ich Spiel genauer hören will, das finde ich schon einen tollen Service, dass ich zum Beispiel in ganzer Länge oder die Bayern hören kann, wenn es eben nirgendswo anders läuft. Weil Radio – gut, während der Champions League und so – gestern hatten wir dann auch Dortmund an, hier über Internetradio ist das dann, glaube ich, oder Kabel. Also jedenfalls diese Event-Sender. Also WDR Event hatte das komplett übertragen. Das höre ich dann schon. Ansonsten ist es ja so, wenn wir hier NDR hören, dann ist es immer gut, wenn München gegen Norddeutsche Klub spielt. Weil es dann ein bisschen mehr an Berichterstattung gibt. Ja, also es gibt mir schon noch was. Es gibt natürlich auch Situats, wo muss ich auch ganz ehrlich sagen, da ziehe ich dann doch manchmal auch, wenn eben mehrere Sachen gleichzeitig angeboten werden, die Fernsehreportage vor. Ein Belaredi zum Beispiel, weil ich dann einfach die Stadionatmosphäre besser mitkriege, als wenn ich dann die Audiodeskription dazuhöre. Weil das haben sie technisch teilweise noch nicht so gut hingekriegt, dass dann die Atmosphäre richtig da ist. Und ich finde es schon auch immer noch interessant, ja, rauszuhören, ja, die Fangesänge oder was auch immer. Das kommt dann ja auch drauf an, in welcher Situation jetzt gerade auch das Fußballspiel läuft, guckt man sich mit wem zusammen oder... Was ganz schrecklich ist, das wäre dann wieder die Geschichte mit Zeitversetzung, wenn du dann eben Radio hörst und der andere guckt Fernsehen und ja, bei mir fällt der Elfmeter halt früher so und ich schreihe dann und dann kriege ich richtig Ärger beim Göttergarten im Nebenzimmer.
Ich stelle davor an, wie guckts Kai Gow, dann weiß er es schon, ich hatte schon...
Ja, aber dann hat man wenigstens noch eine gute Minute, um sich schon zu entschuldigen, bis dann auch die, die in der Kommt, wo man sich wieder konzentrieren muss. Ja, spannend, aber du bist ja dann noch viel, viel mehr vom Kommentator abhängig als sehende Fußballfans, wo es ja auch schon genügend gibt, die einen sterbenden Schwanen-Meme sobald Kommentator XY kommentiert. Und dann wird fröhlich getwittert, Stadionoption jetzt und zwar sofort mit vielen Ausrufezeichen. Wie ist denn das? Hast du noch die Möglichkeit, ein Spiel auch nochmal über andere Berichterstattungen nachzuarbeiten? Hast du manchmal das Gefühl, das wurde jetzt gar nicht so korrekt wiedergegeben? Du bist ja tatsächlich vollkommen von der Schilderung abhängig.
Ja, was ich schon spannend finde, das war jetzt gerade auch letztens bei dem HSV-Gladbach-Spiel wieder so im Stadion, das zu erleben, wo man dann so zwischendurch sich fragt, warum sind die Spiele eigentlich so viel wert bei diesem Geschiebe? Was ist das eigentlich? Und dann sieht man abends die Zusammenfassung, die ja nur ganz kurz ist und wo ja irgendwie klar sein muss, warum der HSV das irgendwie verdient gewonnen hat. Ich meine, das hat er auch verdient. Aber bei der Zusammenfassung habe ich gedacht, ich war bei einem anderen Spiel. Weil die das ganze Spielgeschehen so positiv dargestellt hat. Und ich dachte irgendwie so, hallo, das waren noch so viele Fehlpässe. Und da dachte ich irgendwie, ja, was ist das jetzt? Und habe mir dann damit einfach nur entschuldigen können, dass ich so gedacht habe, okay, die mussten irgendwie auf ihr 3-2 kommen und dass der HSV da halt gewonnen hat. Das muss irgendwie, ja. Aber ansonsten, ja, ich hatte es ja vorhin schon mal gesagt, also Nachberichterstattung, wenn ich irgendwie die Zeit finde, dann natürlich mit meinen Presse-Newslettern. Also die sind ja auch noch in meinem Postfach. Ja, und natürlich jetzt die Schlusskonferenz, ne? Ja, ist wirklich so. Also das ist schon so. Ich meine, ich interessiere mich jetzt nicht so für jeden Verein. Und verfolgt da auch nicht jedes Spiel so detailliert. Und das ist doch nochmal durch die Schlusskonferenz jetzt nochmal ein ganz anderes Erlebnis zum Teil auch. Also einfach nochmal mehr auch fernab wirklich auch von diesem Boulevard die Sachen dann auch mitzubekommen. Deswegen habe ich es auch in unseren Kreisen schon absolut empfohlen.
Das freut mich umso mehr. Und das ist ja jetzt die Situation im Bundesliga-Stadion. Und was würdest du sagen? Sind wir da in Deutschland auf einem guten Weg? Also wenn du sagst, bei vielen Zweitligisten gibt es auch schon und es ist geplant, dass es bald kommt, dann würde ich sagen, das hört sich jetzt gar nicht so schlecht an.
Ob wir jetzt mit den Kopfhörerplätzen auf einem guten Weg sind?
Genau.
Ja, würde ich schon sagen.
Und wo sind so die Bereiche, wo du sagst, gibt es noch Optimierungsmöglichkeiten?
Du hast vorhin gesagt, dass das aus England damals kam, als es in Leverkusen angefangen hat. Haben die das in England gesehen, bei Manchester United? Im Vergleich zu Deutschland, hast du Erfahrungen oder weißt du, wie das heute in anderen Ländern ist? Sind sie in England weiter als wir, wenn sie schon früher dran waren?
Das kann ich nicht sagen. Optimierungsbedarf will ich mal so sagen, aber nur als kurze Andeutung, weil ich da auch nicht näher einsteigen möchte, weil ich das auch eher nur so intern mitkriege. Ich finde es schwierig, also je mehr Leute da sozusagen am werkeln sind und je mehr es auch um Pöstchen geht, findet einfach auch teilweise keine gute Kommunikation statt. Da gibt es jetzt irgendwie so ein Kompetenzzentrum und es gab einen Tag zur Blindenreportage in Leverkusen. Fände ich auch ganz gut, wenn ihr das in den Showdowns auch den Link zur Aktion Menschseite dann noch mit rein stellt, weil man sich da wunderbar dieses Video zur Blindenreportage und zu diesem ganzen ansehen kann. Aber von diesem Blindenreportagetag ist im Vorhinein kaum berichtet worden unter den Reportern. Ich finde zum Beispiel gerade der Bruder aus Hamburg, der das ja mit angeschoben hat, auch diese ganzen Qualitätsgeschichten und so, da wird er, finde ich zum Teil, einfach sehr stiefmütterlich behandelt. Ich finde einfach, da muss man so ein bisschen gucken, dass da Kommunikationswege auch gut laufen, wie überall, wo Menschen zusammenarbeiten.
Was gibt es so für Seiten, die du empfehlen kannst, sowohl für Blinde als auch für andere, die sich einfach fürs Thema interessieren, wo man sich dann im Internet gut informieren kann?
Ja, also aufgebaut wird jetzt diese Seite Blindenreportage. Also wie gesagt, die ist im Aufbau, aber das soll sozusagen auch dahin führen, dass man irgendwann, so wie man früher das Tor des Monats, irgendwie den O-Ton des Monats wählen kann. Das ist vielleicht auch eine ganz witzige Geschichte. Dann natürlich Fanclub Seehunde, also unsere Fanclub-Seite. Weil man dort auch die Information finden kann, erstens, in welchen Stadien gibt es Plätze. Und wir versuchen auch, das immer aktuell zu halten, wie man an diese Tickets kommt, also die entsprechenden Kontakte und so. Übrigens, Würzburg-Hickers startet jetzt auch damit. Wollte ich nur mal so sagen. Ich wollte auch sagen, dem Frank kennen. Ach so, dem Frank.
Ich dachte immer, wenn ich Frank höre, dann fühle ich mich gleich angesprochen und höre für die letzten zwei Buchstaben weg. Stimmt, das habe ich auf der Seehunde-Fanclub-Seite vorhin gesehen. Das ist auch ganz neu.
Und es gibt, um das nochmal zu ergänzen, es gibt auch ein paar Bundesligisten, das möchte ich ja nicht verschweigen, die auch eigene blinden Fanclubs haben. Borussia Dortmund hat einen eigenen Fanclub, Blind Date. Es gibt bei Berlin die Seebären, die sich auch im Fußballbereich und mittlerweile auch noch in anderen Sportarten engagieren.
Das heißt, wenn das jetzt andere Seebehinderte hören, die vielleicht noch nicht den Sprung in Stadion zum Beispiel geschafft haben, dann wären das so die ersten Adressen, die sie an-surfen könnten und wo sie sich informieren können und miteinander verbinden.
Und auch auf der Seite der BBRG, das ist ja die Bundesbehindertenarbeitsgemeinschaft. Die haben auch eine eigene Seite. Aber gerade unsere Seite jetzt von Seehunden, wirklich diese Auflistung mit den Stadion, das ist schon irgendwie ein schneller Zugriff. Also da sieht man dann auch, das es sogar in Erfurt und bei Holstein-Kiel und Braunschweig, also auch wirklich bei kleinen Vereinen solche Angebote gibt. Vielleicht ist es da auch ein bisschen einfacher mit den Karten, wenn man da in der Nähe auch dann wohnt und sich für seinen Ortsverein sozusagen interessiert.
Also packen wir definitiv alles in die Shownotes. Die Links sind alle zu finden. Gibt es denn eigentlich etwas, was auch andere Fußballfans noch besser machen können, wo man Sehbehinderte unterstützen kann? Oder würdest du sagen, da gibt es jetzt gar nicht so viele Berührungspunkte? Ich kann mir das immer noch gar nicht so wirklich vorstellen, wie das ist, nicht sehenden Auges sich durch diese Massen an Menschen zu schieben. Gibt es da irgendwelche Dinge, die für euch wichtig sind, auf die ich vielleicht gar nicht jetzt gekommen wäre?
Naja, ich sage jetzt mal ganz ketzerisch. Jeder, der sich mit Bengalos oder mit irgendwelchen Geschichten im Stadion daneben benimmt, der bringt Leute in Gefahr. Und der bringt natürlich auch Behinderte in Gefahr. Ich sage mal, die Situation, eine Geschichte in Leverkusen zum Beispiel, die haben die Plätze vorher, das fand ich wunderbar, die hatten die Kopfhörerplätze direkt neben dem Stehblock der Gästefans. Es war für mich immer ein wundervolles Spiel in Leverkusen gegen Bayern, weil ich direkt neben den Gesängen saß. Die haben die Plätze jetzt auf die andere Seite des Tores, also nach rechts verlegt, nachdem nicht nur der Reporter, sondern eben auch Leute auf unseren Plätzen dann mit vollem Bier und Urinbechern und sonst was von den Kölnern beworfen wurden. Also das war einfach zu gefährlich, die Plätze in dieser Ecke zu lassen. Unsere Fanclub-Leitung – ich hatte das ja vorhin schon angesprochen – Regina und Nina sind in Köln unterwegs und haben dort Kontakte zum Fanprojekt und auch zu den Ultras und sagen eben auch, sie finden das auch ganz wichtig, auch denen einfach auch so bewusst zu machen. Es gibt auch Leute, die eben da nicht so schnell wegrennen oder was auch immer können, wenn Situationen einfach sind. Insgesamt würde ich mir wünschen, das ist aber jetzt nicht nur bezogen auf Fußballfans, sondern das ist ja so generell einfach offen zu sein und wenn man eher unsicher ist, nicht irgendwie die Augen schließen und sich an die Seite stellen und versuchen, vorbei zu schleichen, sondern eher irgendwie zu verbalisieren. Also ich finde das ganz oft schwierig im Kontakt mit Sehenden. Ich kann das immer erklären. Ich weiß, warum Sehende sich so verhalten, aber es macht es mir eben noch schwieriger, wenn Leute eben einfach versuchen, sich um die Situation drumherum zu lavieren. Also leise zur Seite zu gehen und ich gehe dann vielleicht mit meinem Stock trotzdem in die Richtung, wo die Leute gerade stehen. Also eine Ansprache, Achtung, hier stehe ich oder kannst du schlecht gucken oder irgendwie. Also lieber offen verbalisieren als irgendwie zu meinen, ich habe da jetzt Angst vor. Finde ich sehr schwierig. Und die Situation, sage ich jetzt mal, vor einem Eingang zur S-Bahn nach dem Spiel, wo man eben zerquetscht und zerdrückt wird. Die ist ja nun, also muss ich euch nicht sagen, die ist ja für alle schwierig. Und wenn du da ein kleines Kind dabei hast, ist es irgendwie auch schwierig. Und wenn du dann eben so Besoffene dabei hast, die nicht mehr so genau wissen, was sie tun oder einfach nur gut drauf sind und jetzt wollen wir mal von hinten oh, jetzt springen wir da mal rein und schubsen so ein bisschen. Also da gab es jetzt auch so zwei, drei Situationen, wo ich so gedacht habe, boah, muss ich mir sowas irgendwie noch so antun? Weil ich wirklich das Gefühl hatte, ja, ich wäre zerquetscht, obwohl mein Begleiter groß ist und versucht, so einen Raum zu schaffen. Aber da muss ich auch sagen, es gibt immer, und das möchte ich auch an dieser Stelle ganz deutlich sagen, ich habe immer in diesen, ja, angstbesetzten Situationen immer wieder auch erlebt, dass andere Leute wahrnehmen, dass ich mit meinem Blindenstock, dass ich da bin, und versuchen, die anderen, ja, also mich quasi zu schützen. Also, wildfremde Leute. Also, die dann versuchen, die entweder sogar sagen, ey, pass doch mal auf, oder die wirklich versuchen, mit ihrem Arm irgendwie diesen Freiraum so zu schaffen. Und das finde ich schon auch sehr schön so.
Ja, es reduziert sich dann letztlich dann doch wieder einfach auf gesunden Menschenverstand und Respekt im Umgang miteinander, wenn man ehrlich ist.
Ganz genau.
Klar, und der fehlt halt natürlich oft bei vielen in solchen Situationen, eben wie du sagst, betrunken oder im Siegesrausch oder wie auch immer. Da wäre einfach ein bisschen mehr Respekt wahrscheinlich insgesamt angebracht. Und speziell natürlich Menschen gegenüber, die dann zusätzlich eingeschränkt sind.
Ja, aber grundsätzlich nochmal, ich habe es ja vorhin auch schon mal gesagt, durch diese vielen Erlebnisse im Fußball und so habe ich einfach, durch dieses gemeinsame Interesse, meine Offenheit, aber eben wirklich auch dieses Ja, da ist man dann zusammen im Stehblock, auf der gleichen Wellenlänge habe ich wirklich einfach auch viele tolle Kontakte kennengelernt. Teilweise sind sie noch, teilweise natürlich nicht mehr, weil sich da die Lebenswege einfach verändern, aber da habe ich viel, viel Positives auch draus gezogen.
Ja gut, und du hast Dinge erlebt, meine Güte. Norwich City gegen Nottingham Forest im September 87, da lecken sich andere die Finger nach. Also schon erstaunlich, was man dann auch wirklich, wenn man einfach begeistert für die Sache ist und viele Dinge auf sich nimmt, hast du ja auch thematisiert, dann kann man schon auch wirklich tolle Sachen erleben und das dann auf eine ganz andere Art und Weise. Wie ist es denn jetzt, wenn du heute so im Amateurfußball unterwegs bist? Ich könnte mir vorstellen, so ganz banale Frage, aber wenn neben mir jemand stehen würde, der Sehbegleitung ist und der dann die ganze Zeit das Spiel kommentiert und das dann vielleicht nur so mittelgut macht, ich weiß nicht, ob ich das aushalten könnte. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich dann nicht entweder sagen würde, kannst ich bitte machen, oder ob ich den Platz wechseln würde. Ist dir sowas schon mal passiert? Fühlen sich die Leute vielleicht auch manchmal gestört?
Ja, so ein- zweimal hat das schon. Also ich habe das schon mal erlebt, dass jemand mal verbessert wurde. Aber na gut, ich meine, ich sehe das ja nicht, ob einer dann weggeht. Ich meine, wenn du weggehst, bist du weg. Du sagst ja jetzt nicht, das nervt mich, ich gehe jetzt weg, sondern du gehst dann halt.
Ja klar, würde ich ja auch nicht tun. Ich meine, das ist ja eine Form.
Nein, aber ich meine, wenn das so ist, wenn sich jemand gestört fühlt. Was ganz witzig ist, also weil du jetzt den Amateurfußball ansprichst, ich hatte das ja vorhin auch schon angedeutet, ich bin, also 2006 war so ein Jahr, da habe ich irgendwie so- war ich irgendwann mal satt, weil ich eigentlich alles erlebt habe, was man erleben konnte. Ich bin mit Bayern Meister geworden und war sozusagen beim letzten Heimspiel da. Ich war das erste und einzige Mal beim Pokalspiel in Berlin und habe da den Sieg miterlebt. Ich bin Weltmeister geworden, weil ich bin großer Italien-Fan. Das war, ich habe Weltmeisterschaftsspiele erlebt mit diesen Blindenkarten. Also ich war insgesamt sechs WM-Spielen hier in Deutschland in Stadien. Ich war einfach, ja, ich war irgendwie so satt. Also ich hatte dann wirklich so ein halbes Jahr, wo ich irgendwie Bundesliga-Fußball nur so am Rande. Das war einfach, irgendwann ist das mal gut. Man kann man irgendwie nicht mehr erreichen. Und durch einen Begleiter, also ich habe ja mit meinen WM-Spielen fünf verschiedene Männer glücklich gemacht, die mich sozusagen zum Spielen begleiten durften, bin ich eben über einen. Der hat selber hier im Kreis Pinneberg in einer Mannschaft auf Kreisklasse oder Kreisligaebene gespielt. Kreisklasse war es glaube ich damals. Bin ich dann halt das erste Mal, weil ich so gedacht habe, oh, dann gehe ich mal dahin, wo der spielt, bin ich also zum Kreisklassen-Fußball gegangen. Und das habe ich, ja ich glaube, das war so eine Zeit vier, fünf Jahre sind wir, mein Mann und ich, regelmäßig hingegangen. Und das war schon nochmal eine ganz andere Situation. Zum Eilen, weil man die Spieler, die Mannschaft und die Funktionäre und so eben kannte und sich teilweise selbst engagiert hat, also ich habe dann auch für den Verkauf Kuchen gebacken und sowas alles. Man war direkt am Spielfeldrand, also hinter der Stange, also direkt am Spielfeld. Da gab es dann so Situationen, dass mal so eine Geschichte war, dass mein Mann irgendwie meinte abseits und der Schiri sich umdrehte und sagte, das entscheide ich. Dem haben wir dann erklärt, warum da diese Erklärungen kommen. Das Spiel ist nicht so klasse, dass da jemand immer irgendwas sagte. Und lustig war, dass – ja, die Reportage war wohl gut genug, dass ich meistens immer zur richtigen Zeit den entsprechenden Namen unserer Mannschaft, also des Spielers, gerufen habe. Die waren manchmal etwas irritiert, weil sie eigentlich wussten, ich bin blind und konnten überhaupt nicht verstehen, warum ich dann plötzlich den entsprechenden richtigen Ruf loswerden konnte. Ja, ganz genau, das war wirklich so. Das war an manchen ein bisschen irritiert. Das haben die jetzt im Nachhinein ein paar Leute auch nochmal so gesagt, so in Gesprächen. Und ich kann es nicht erklären, weil es ist einfach so, ich kann irgendwie ein Spiel, wie sagt man, ich kann irgendwie ein Spiel lesen. Also es ist tatsächlich so, dass ich oft einfach das richtige Gefühl für die Dinge habe, die da irgendwie passieren oder noch kommen. Was ich dann aber nicht näher beschreiben kann. Also durch das, was ich höre, und das ist natürlich bei so einer Kreisliga-Geschichte, wo du halt direkt dastehst und dann auch die Spielerreaktion hörst und Gespräche von einer Bank und so. Da ist das ja nochmal verschärfter, was man da einfach so mitnehmen kann, wenn man eben nicht durchs Visuelle abgelenkt ist. Ich habe eine Situation mal erlebt. Der Oli Fritsch ist ja mittlerweile, hatte ich ja vorhin erwähnt, Freistoß. Den Pressenspiegel hat er ja sozusagen initiiert. Der ist mittlerweile bei Zeit Online. Wir hatten zwischendurch öfter mal Mailkontakt, viele Jahre. Er war mal Trainer hier in Hamburg bei SV Blankenese. Da hatte ich natürlich den Anspruch, dass ich ihn ja gerne auch mal persönlich treffen wollte und ihn als Trainer auch mal erleben wollte. Ich bin dann zu einem Pokalspiel gegangen. Da hat Blankenese gegen Tornetsch hier bei mir im Kreis gespielt. Blankenese war, glaube ich, von der Position der Liga sogar eine höher und hat aber dieses Pokalspiel verloren. Da waren auch ganz viele Sachen mit roter Karte. Jedenfalls habe ich dann Olli am nächsten Tag meinen Eindruck geschrieben und habe auch ein paar Sachen geschrieben, nach Spielern gefragt. Ich habe ein paar Sachen, die ich beobachtet hatte, geschrieben. Dann hat er nur zurückgeschrieben, dass er mir mal meine Spiele anzeigen darf. Das wäre unglaublich, was ich da treffend formuliert habe. Da habe ich nur so gedacht, ich habe doch ein bisschen Ahnung.
Das heißt, es ist gar keine Beleidigung, wenn Lobby Dickel im Fanradio schreit, Schiri, du Blinder. Eigentlich lobt er damit, seine Fähigkeiten das Spiel zu lesen.
Ja, vielleicht die Schiri ich auch mal so verstehe. Vielleicht noch mal zum Auslandsfußball. Ich habe mir zumindest einen Traum auch erfüllt. Du hattest ja vorhin gesagt, diese Geschichte in England, das war ja, ich sage jetzt mal, purer netter Zufall, wo ich jetzt in meiner Biografie sagen kann, ich war auch mal in England beim Fußball. Aber mein großer Traum war ja auch mal nach Italien zum Fußball. Und die Nationalmannschaft von Italien habe ich schon mehrfach gesehen, aber eben immer nur in Deutschland. Länderspiel von Italien in Italien habe ich leider noch nicht geschafft. Aber ich habe mir mein Traum erfüllt. Ich war einmal in Turin. Und zwar war ich, ich glaube, 2014 im März, also es war zumindest ein Ligaspiel, die Event des Turin gegen AC Florenz. Und das war sonntagsmittags. Da waren wir also von freitags bis montags in Turin. Und dienstagsmorgens sind wir dann, also wir sind montags hier nach Hamburg zurückgekommen und sind dann am Dienstag zum Champions League-Spiel nach München gefahren.
Das ist nicht so schlecht. Und durch die Ohren einer Blinden, was sind die Unterschiede?
Also was mich in Turin schon beeindruckt hat, also erstmal ist es ja sehr schwierig an Karten zu kommen. Deswegen habe ich das Ganze über ein Reisebüro organisieren lassen von Flug und Hotel, also quasi mit diesen Tickets, die dann im Hotel für uns zurückgelegt waren. Und die Karten sind ja personalisiert. Und ich konnte mir überhaupt nicht vorstellen, gut man kennt es von der WM, aber jetzt so beim normalen Liga-Alltag, ich konnte mir überhaupt nicht vorstellen, wie das dann an den Eingängen ist. Ich dachte, das muss ja ewig lange dauern. So, jetzt war ja erstmal die Besonderheit, dass das ein Sonntagsmittagsspiel ist, um halb eins war das. Wir sind von unserem Hotel aus mit einem normalen Stadtbus zum Stadion gefahren. Der kam an und war schon rappelvoll. Vielleicht lag es an der Mittagszeit, aber wenn ich mal vergleiche, so eine volle Busfahrt, also auch schon auf dem Hinweg hier, und das, was ich dort erlebt habe, muss ich sagen, wow, was diszipliniert. Also es war richtig ruhig, es wurde auch nicht gesungen oder so, aber es war auch nicht so dieses Sich-Anbrüllen oder dieses Geschupse. Also schon als wir einstiegen, standen wir schon im Eingangsbereich einfach sehr Sardin-mäßig und dann hat Papa seinen Sohn auf den Schoß genommen und dann konnte ich mich damit hinsetzen. Dann sind wir sogar ins Gespräch gekommen auf Englisch und der Sohn war großer Vidal-Fan und so. Dann sind wir an das Stadion gekommen und dann war er so aufgebaut. Klar gab es auch so ein paar Essensboden, aber irgendwie auch noch so ein Kinderkarussell oder sowas. Dann kamen wir da hin und so schnell war ich noch nie im deutschen Stadion wie dort. Ich habe gar keine Ahnung. Keine riesen Schlangen. Die haben auf den Personalausweis auf die Karte geguckt und schwups waren wir drin. Dann fand ich die Preise interessant. Ich meine, wenn du das Geld zusammenrechnest, war es natürlich genauso wie hier, aber anders. Der Schwerpunkt war anders. Wasser war total günstig, ein großes Wasser. Hier zahlts ja auch 4, 50 Euro oder so. Aber da war das erschwinglich. Dafür war die Wurst entsprechend teuer und auch nicht lecker. Dann war es interessant mit den Toiletten. Das hätte ich jetzt bei Italien gar nicht erwartet. Ich glaube, in der Halbzeit muss ich aufs Klo. Es ist ja überall voll. Dann bin ich da auf die Frauentoilette und komme raus und sage nur zu meinem Mann, da waren Männer. Das ist irgendwie komisch. Da waren Männer. Dann hat er das wirklich bestätigt. Weil bei den Männern so eine riesen Schlange war, sind die Männer da mit auf die Frauentoiletten. Das habe ich zumindest hier in Deutschland noch nicht erlebt. Ich hätte es gerade von Italien auch nicht erwartet. Dass Männer da auf die Frauentoiletten gehen, das fand ich ziemlich lustig.
Und wie war es dann so vom Support während des Spiels? Was ist denn jetzt dann eigentlich für dich, jetzt nur aus deiner Perspektive gesprochen, besser? Spielbezogener Support, also wäre für dich eigentlich ein Geisterspiel perfekt, weil man da richtig den Ball auch manchmal hört. Manchmal hört man, was die Spieler rufen. Oder wie hättest du es am liebsten?
Da sagst du was Beides. Ich hätte gerne mal ein Geisterspiel, aber wo dann auch jemand neben mir steht, der mir dann auch sagen kann, wen die da rufen hören. Das wäre schon mal interessant. Aber ansonsten natürlich ist es mit Support-Klasse. Also und zwar spielbezogener Support. Also ich möchte irgendwie nicht 0 zu 4 mit meiner Mannschaft zurückliegen und dann singen meine Fans dann immer noch und feiern sich selbst. Das finde ich dann irgendwie auch, weiß ich nicht, nicht angemessen.
Macht das für dich auch schwieriger, ein Spiel zu lesen in dem Sinne, dass halt heutzutage, also ich kenn's ja von vielen Bayernspielen, 85. Minute gegen alle Stadionverbote und zwar ganz egal, wie steht. 0 zu 8 oder 8 zu 0 ist egal. Kannst du trotzdem an der Art und Weise wie gerufen wird, noch Veränderungen wahrnehmen oder ist das für dich auch schwierig? Also ich blende das ehrlich gesagt dann manchmal aus. Also wenn ich nicht mitsinge, was bei manchen einer Art von Fangesängen vorkommt, alles was so mit anderen Mannschaften zu tun hat, das interessiert mich in dem Moment nicht, dann bin ich voll aufs Spiel fokussiert und dann kriege ich manchmal auch gar nicht mehr mit, dass die jetzt das schon seit drei Minuten singen und steigt dann erst später wieder ein, wenn sie was singen, was sich auf meine Mannschaft bezieht, wo ich mitsinge. Geht dir das auch so oder?
Ja, ich glaube schon, dass es dann schwieriger wird. Man hat natürlich immer noch Leute im Stadion, die erschrocken reagieren, wenn der Ball fast ins eigene Tor fällt. So ein bisschen kriegt man es dann doch noch mit. Vielleicht höre ich auch mehr Nuancen, aber grundsätzlich macht es das dann schon schwieriger. Dein zweiter Teil – da bin ich dann nicht so ganz bei dir – finde dann kreative Lieder gegen die anderen Vereine dann schon auch mal ganz nett. Also ich habe dann in Leverkusen schon mitgesogen, ihr werdet nie Deutscher Meister oder unter Haching angefeuert als Bayern-Fan. Das muss man dann in Leverkusen halt mal machen.
Ja, ich beziehe mich da ehrlich gesagt. Also in Freiburg, ich habe ja an Freiburg studiert und war da viel im Stadion. Da ist jetzt auch nicht alles golden, aber da gab es schon manchmal. Also es ist kein Zufall, dass es aus Freiburg kam mit dem Idrissou, spielt Champions League auf der PS3. Aber ehrlich gesagt langweilt mich ein BVB-Huansöhne oder ein Tod und Hass, dem TSV oder auch dem FCN. Das ist mir doch vollkommen egal, wenn wir gerade irgendwie zuhause gegen Werder spielen.
Ja, das ist richtig. Ja, das ist natürlich richtig. Ja, macht es schwieriger. Naja, und der Support in Italien. Also da muss ich sagen, wir haben viele Sachen leider natürlich auch erst wegen unserer fehlenden Sprachkenntnisse erst im Nachhinein erfahren. Da sind auch gerade bei dem Spiel Turin und Florenz nicht so tolle Sachen gelaufen. Also so rassistische Sachen sind da gelaufen, beziehungsweise die Florenz-Fans hatten irgendwie dann auch so ein Plakat mit zwei Spielern, Cillini und irgend wem anderen, da irgendwie so bezogen auf diese Juwel-Fans, die da bei dem Heisel-Drama ums Leben gekommen sind. Also ganz unschöne Sachen und Affengeräusche und so was alles. Und die Turina hatten an dem Tag irgendwie noch so eine Fan-Freundschaft, die sich gejährt hat, gefeiert, auch mit irgendeiner schwierigen Gruppe da aus Holland. Das haben wir leider erst im Nachhinein erfahren, weil wir eine Nachbarin haben, die Italienisch spricht und die uns dann die entsprechenden Zeitungsartikeln, die danach kamen, auch vorgelesen hat. Mein Mann hat die Zeitung dann halt im Flugzeug gesehen mit dem entsprechenden Bild. Und dann haben wir die halt mitgenommen und uns das hier übersetzen lassen. Und dadurch haben wir halt mitgekriegt, dass da schon so ein paar Sachen waren. Und der eine Blog, der Auswärtsblog, der neben uns war, der war auch nicht ganz ausverkauft. Also da war wohl auch schon irgendwie eine Blogsperre gewesen. Ansonsten, ja, war es auch so ein bisschen, wie ich das vorhin schon so vom Event-Tempel hier gesagt habe. Es war natürlich ein bisschen Support, aber es war ganz oft auch irgendwie wenig. Also, ja, wie man ja manchmal auch so den Bayern-Fans nachsagt, das wären irgendwie, naja, das sind dann halt so die Erfolgsfans oder so, wo irgendwie nicht mehr so viel an Stimmung und so rüberkommt. Und das war bei Juve auch so ein bisschen. Toll war die Mannschaftsaufstellung, toll war dieses Lied, was sie immer spielen. Das ist ja nun jetzt kein richtig schnelles, sondern eher so ein langsam getragenes. Aber das war einfach ganz toll, wie sie das alle mitsingen. Also auch die Leute drumrum dann die Texte mitsingen und so. Also was auch wieder gigantisch ist, ich habe Tonaufnahmen gemacht. Also ich habe ein ganz tolles Mikro dabei gehabt und eben natürlich nicht das ganze Spiel aufgenommen, sondern eben die Mannschaftsaufstellung und das Lied und dann immer so Passagen im Spiel. So kurz vor der Halbzeit und dann mal hier zehn Minuten und mal hier zehn Minuten. Ja und das Spiel ging eins zu null für Juve aus und ich habe das Tor drauf. Ist das nicht göttlich?
Ja, sehr gut.
Mit der Reportage meines Mannes und ja, dass eben das Tor fällt. Und was meinem Mann halt aufgefallen ist, das ist natürlich jetzt nur so ein Einzel-Eindruck, aber wir hatten uns in der Halbzeit dann halt so an die Bande gestellt und da hat ein Ordner uns sofort so zurückgepfiffen, also weg von der Bande. Das haben wir dann natürlich auch gemacht und dann hat mein Mann gesehen, auch so ein Turid-Fan hatte sich an die Bande gestellt und hat auch sofort, als der Ordner was sagte, den Rückzieher gemacht. Und hier, finde ich, erlebt man ja ganz oft, dass dann erst mal diskutiert wird, ey Alter, was willst du und so. Und da sagt man so, das wäre jetzt beim HSV oder so ganz anders gewesen. Also das fand er gut, aber es war eine Momentaufnahme. Also da kann ich jetzt überhaupt nichts verallgemeinern. Was schade war, wir haben Samstag, Samstag sind wir schon mal zum Stadion und haben dort dieses Museum besucht, also so wie das Bayern ja auch hat. Das ist ja ähnlich bei Turin. Ich habe leider im Vorhinein, weil ich da immer mich so ein bisschen schwer tue, wenn alles nur auf Englisch ist, ich habe halt keine Stadionführung im Internet gebucht und dachte, das können wir noch vor Ort. Ja, und das konnten wir leider nicht. Es war nichts zu machen, selbst mein Nurhold da und aus Deutschland und so. Es half nichts. Wir sind also leider nicht in die Stadionführung gekommen. Und die haben die halt so angeboten, dass man wohl auch so Audio Guides gekriegt hätte. Also mit der entsprechenden Sprache. Und ja, ich fürchte, ich muss da dann nochmal hin. Weil das hätte ich schon gerne gemacht.
Gibt es dann eigentlich einen bestimmten Grund, warum Turin nur wegen der Nähe? Oder ist da eine spezielle Beziehung dadurch ja auch vorhin, als es um die Zuneigung zu anderen Mannschaften als dem FC Bayern ging, auch erwähnt, dass du nächste Woche zum Spiel noch was vorhast? Gibt es zu Turin eine spezielle Beziehung?
Also ich bin einfach Turin-Fan in Italien, also von Juve schon ganz lange. Es sind ja auch viele Nationalspieler, die ich einfach gut finde bei Turin. Also Cillini und früher eben Samprata und Cannavara und so. Es ist halt Juve, wobei ich sagen muss, das passt natürlich jetzt auch nicht. Ich finde es auch schon beeindruckend, was Neapel macht und finde Neapel auch gut. Das liegt aber dann auch tatsächlich daran, weil mein Vater aus der Nähe von Neapel kommt. Ich bin so Juve-Fan und mit nächster Woche meinte ich einfach – und da kommen wir jetzt wieder zu den Geschichten, die mich einfach auch beim Fußball interessieren, wo ich dann eben manchmal auch eine nicht mehrheitsfähige Meinung habe – ich habe mich sehr, sehr, sehr darüber geärgert, wie Bayern mit Mandzukic am Schluss umgegangen ist. Ich war beim HSV-Spiel in der Liga – ich weiß gar nicht, ob es das letzte oder vorletzte Liga-Spiel war – wo er nicht eingesetzt wurde. Es hat mich maßlos geärgert, wie man verhindert hat, aus meiner Sicht, dass er Torschützenkönig wird. Ich fand das unmöglich. Und was ich mit nächster Woche gemeint habe, mein größter Wunsch – also mir ist schon klar, dass Bayern gegen Juve weiterkommt, aber mein größter Wunsch ist wirklich, dass Mandzukic ein Tor schießt, ein Tor für Pep Guardiola. Also er muss unbedingt treffen, das wünsche ich mir aus ganzem, ganzem Herzen. Das würde ich ihm so, so gönnen. Und ich fand es sehr schade, dass er im Hinspiel eher übermotiviert war und ich froh sein kann, dass er keinen Rot gekriegt hat. Ich hoffe, dass er am Mittwoch seine Nerven im Griff hat und ja, für mich ein Tor schießt. Das wäre wörtlich.
Womit auch klar wäre, dass wir dieses Tribünengespräch jetzt aber auch wirklich schnell veröffentlichen müssen.
Nein, weil dann auch mein Wunsch in Erfüllung gegangen ist oder nicht. Aber das sind so Sachen, die stören mich. Und wenn sie dann so kommen, finde ich sie dann einfach auch toll. Es gibt ja dann so Geschichten, wie sie der Fußball schreibt. Wenn dann irgendwie ein ehemaliger Spieler genau bei dem Verein dann ein Tor schießt oder so. Solche Sachen finde ich dann einfach irgendwie auch nett. Wenn sie nicht gerade gegen meinen Club sind.
Du bist halt einfach ein Fußballfan, durch und durch.
Ja, und ich finde es auch übrigens toll. Ich bin mal gespannt, was Samstag jetzt passiert. Ich finde es auch toll, wenn Spieler von denen, wenn sie zu ihrer Stätte zurückkehren und dann einfach da vorher ein gutes Standing hatten und dann auch wirklich super begrüßt werden. Also ich glaube, Ulrich ist so ein Fall, also als der mit Hamburg – ne, mit Wolfsburg war er glaube ich damals da. Ich weiß gar nicht genau, wo er auch vorgeschossen hat. Wo dann die Fans trotzdem gut reagiert haben. Und ich bin jetzt sehr gespannt und wünsche mir einfach auch, dass sie Pizarro super empfangen, weil Pizarro ist einfach, das finde ich ganz, ganz toll.
Ich glaube, davon kann man ausgehen, ja.
Schauen wir mal, ob das Spieltraining abgebrochen ist. Aber jetzt rutschen wir gerade von einem Tribünengespräch in eine Schlusskonferenz rein.
Entschuldigung?
Ne, ne, du, alles gut. Wir mögen halt den Fußball und reden gern drüber.
Genau.
Ja Pina, gibt es denn noch irgendwas, was du gerne noch loswerden wollen würdest? Wir haben dich ganz schön ausgepresst, finde ich.
Ja, ich habe ja natürlich auch viel geredet, von mir aus. Ich habe euch ja kaum fragen lassen.
So sollte es ja sein.
Ja, durchaus. Wäre schlimm, wenn es anders um gewesen wäre.
Also ich glaube, es ist schon rausgekommen, dass ich eben zumindest in früherer Zeit einfach ganz, ganz viel in Bewegung gesetzt habe, um irgendwie das zu erreichen und zu schaffen, was ich irgendwie machen möchte. Und ja, das kann ich nur jedem anderen irgendwie empfehlen, so Mut zu haben, auch wenn nicht alles immer glatt geht. Ich finde es jetzt so ein bisschen schade, dass ich so viel zu tun habe. Und naja, gut, ich meine, man ist ja auch irgendwie keine 25 oder 30 mehr. Zumindest ich nicht. Ich merke einfach auch, ich kann einfach auch nicht mehr so viel unterwegs sein. Also wenn man dann arbeitet. Also ein bisschen schade finde ich das. Aber es hat halt irgendwie so alles seine Zeit. Und ja, jetzt bin ich halt doch eher, ich sage jetzt mal, der normale Fußballkonsument geworden. Und ich kenne auch längst, also am Anfang habe ich mir immer vorgenommen, jeden neuen Kopfhörerplatz auch kennenzulernen. Da bin ich mittlerweile schon weit von entfernt. Ich drücke jetzt dann immer so die Daumen, dass bestimmte Leute nicht absteigen oder so, damit ich sie dann weiter in Hamburg auch dann mal sehen kann. Also, dass sie halt hier hinkommen.
Ja, so hat halt alles seine Zeit. Aber definitiv warst du sicher auch ein Bestandteil, dass sich für Sehbehinderte in Stadion viel verändert hat. Das ist jetzt, glaube ich, auch rausgekommen. Und einfach eine wahnsinnig interessante Fernbiografie. Ich bin neidisch auf ganz viele Erfahrungen, die du gemacht hast. Und habe mich sehr gefreut, dass du dir so ausführlich Zeit genommen hast für dieses Tribünengespräch.
Ja, vielen Dank, dass sich das einfach mal jemand, oder sogar zwei Leute und dann vielleicht auch noch draußen Hörer, sich Zeit nehmen und nicht einfach so viel erzählen konnte und durfte.
Hat mir sehr gut gefallen. Und ich bin sicher auch unseren Hörern. Und wir werden große Freude daran haben, das Feedback dann eigentlich weiterzuleiten.
Genau, exakt. Ja, in diesem Sinne vielen Dank für ein sehr interessantes Tribünengespräch. Ich hoffe sehr, dass es den Hörern auch gefallen hat. Mir persönlich hat es sehr gefallen, dass ich es zu zweit moderieren durfte.
Der Zaunpfahl ist kaum zu übersehen.
Genau, der akustische Zaunpfahl. Und gerne auch liebe Hörer da draußen, Ed Helmi. Man kann ihm auch bei Twitter schreiben und einfach fragen, hey, wann moderierst du denn nochmal? Hey, mir fehlt deine Stimme. Das sind so SMS, die schicke ich ihm auch gerne mal nachts. Du fehlt mir. Naja, mir hat es Spaß gemacht.
Mir auch, Max.
Dann sind wir uns alle einig. Sehr schön. Liebe Hörer, danke, dass ihr diese Folge gehört habt. Wenn ihr Feedback habt, schickt es uns gerne. Wir leiten das alles auch sehr gerne weiter an Pina. Pina, dir nochmal ganz herzlichen Dank. Würde mich sehr freuen, wenn wir uns vielleicht irgendwann mal treffen. Sag einfach mal Bescheid, wenn du in der Nähe bist. Und ich mache es wie zu versa.
Änderspiel.
Da könnte sich vielleicht sogar tatsächlich was ergeben.
Ja, werde ich auf jeden Fall vorher dir nochmal Bescheid sagen. Da habe ich dann ja meinen internen Familienkrieg. Sehr gut. Mein Mann hofft auf sein Geburtstagsgeschenk und ich hoffe, dass es vermasselt wird.
Ui, da bin ich gespannt. Ja, melde dich. Ich bin da beruflich wahrscheinlich, aber da kriegen wir vielleicht was hin. Das würde mich freuen. Da haben wir schon einen Termin am Horizont. Liebe Hörer, danke fürs Hören. Liebe Pina, danke fürs Mitmachen. Lieber Frank, danke, dass es dich gibt. Und in diesem Sinne, bis zum nächsten Tribünengespräch, wahrscheinlich dann im vierten Quartal 2017. Bis dahin, euch eine gute Zeit. Hört schön brav die Schlusskonferenz. Und bis dahin, macht's gut.
Das war das Rasenfunk Tribünengespräch.